Hình như là mình bắt đầu hơi
sớm mình đang muố ấn các bạn nghe được
không ạ Alo em nghe được không Alo
alo
ờ anh ấn nh nút stream ấy kiểu Anh đang
test lại mà
Ờ còn chưa ghi thông báo cái gì cả th
báo gì rồi chào T thông báo bảo tặng đâ
như thế
đại chưởng Đợi tí Đợi tí đợi tí
[âm nhạc]
Ờ chào các bạn ầ rất lâu rồi mới được nó
chuyện lại với các bạn
Ừ đợi mình một tí
nhá mở cái link này lên
à đầu tiên là xin chào các bạn
thể điền được câu hỏi nhá nhiều phết
Đợi mình chỉnh lại cái con câu hỏi này
cho nó nhìn nó rõ
hơn chế độ
và thực ra là tôi cố tình để cái chế độ
chính câu hỏi ở đây để ông nào đăng lên
đây thì có thể xem được luôn
ấy link discord á link discord có trong
phần mô tả của video ấy em thể vào được
nhá Mấy ông nghe được tôi nói gì không
nhỉ Alo Có mà đúng
à OK OK Bởi vì bây giờ chuyển quá mát
kiểu phải setting Lại hết một loạt x rồi
Hình như cái mic của tôi còn đang không
tương thích với M lắm các bạn sẽ thấy là
giọng nó không như có người bảo là giọng
nó không được trầm Mấm như hồi trước như
mấy cái video trước chắc là để hôm sau
tôi ngồi mò lại
cả
mic nói chung là nói chung còn phải
chỉnh lại khá là nhiều Ừ đúng như có bạn
đ ý là tôi đã chuyển qua dùng m rồi Nói
chung là
Ờ lần cuối chúng ta livestream là cũng
đây kiểu đúng một năm rồi đúng không À
thì sau 1 năm thì tôi có rất nhiều thay
đổi đấy Thy chuyển hệ điều hành này
à code mọi thứ cũng rất là khác hôm nay
thực ra là tôi không hẳn là định
code hôm nay đâu à code thì chắc là chắc
là để buổi sau để tôi còn là chuẩn bị
lại mọi thứ
Xem soạn lại giá oán cẩn thận xem là
mình sẽ code sẽ like code những cái gì
nữa tôi định like code cả làm tiện x
hoặc là like code làm một cái gì nà khác
cũng không chắc là sẽ D tiếp tục cái dự
án cũ vì bây giờ tôi đọc lại dự án cũ
Tôi muốn đập đi làm lại quá hoặc là bây
giờ mình có thể đập đi làm lại luôn cũng
được để cho các bạn biết được là
Ờ tôi Sau Một năm đã chưởng thành code
đã chưng thành hơn như thế nào Đúng là
hôm nay nói chung là hôm nay tôi xin các
bạn một buổi chỉ để tâm sự thôi đúng
không ạ Tâm
chính tôi nữa
và đặt câu hỏi các thứ tôi sẽ giải đáp
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là ừ sau 1
năm người ấy đã thay đổi như thế nào
đúng không ạ
thì có thể là những câu hỏi mà các bạn
đã từng hỏi tôi hồi trước chắc chắn là
bây giờ tôi sẽ có câu trả lời theo kiểu
khác tôi cảm thấy
thế thì tại sao năm nay tôi khẳng định
được là tôi thay đổi yếu thế có nghĩa là
có một cái bước ngoặt bước ngoặt gần đây
lớn nhất với tôi tôi thường hay khoe
điều đấy đó à Tôi Khoe nhiều lắm kiểu
như kiểu dạng
là như kiểu tôi khoe lúc kiểu tôi cả
tưởng là như kiểu là đây Tôi thường có
khoe là tôi có anh ship mới đấy cái việc
tôi Khoe nhiều nhắc đến tên anh thấy
nhiều làm ai cũng tưởng giống như tôi có
nhiêu mới vậy
à Tôi sẽ khoe anh đấy luôn ở đây là anh
Bình à người xếp của tôi cho dù là mới
mới quen rất là gần gần đây
thôi nhưng mà gọi như là người đấy đến
và lúc mà tôi đang cũng gặp rất nhiều
khủng hoảng rất nhiều vấn đề và anh ấy
anh ấy thực ra 96 hơn tôi một tuổi thôi
Nhưng mà sự trải đời hay mọi thứ của anh
đấy khiến cho tôi kiểu cảm thấy là mình
trẻ con ắ mình trẻ con sao
mình kiểu dạng là mình đúng là cần có
những người mà kiểu đầu tiên là thấu
hiểu mình đã thứ hai là đưa cho mình
được khuyên ngay tại cái điểm đấy để cho
đây để tôi thử kể ông các ông kiểu lúc
đấy nhá Tôi vẫn nhớ là Ờ hôm đấy anh này
kém tôi ra chỗ riêng để nói xong rồi anh
ấy bảo là thật ra anh mới vào công ty
mình được hai ngày thôi nhưng mà anh
nghĩ là bây giờ em đang cần lời khuyên
anh thấy là em đang
ờ
kiểu kiểu dạng là hợc bơ cho cái dự án
mới này nhưng có vẻ em đang work hot chứ
không phải work Smart đấy và em có vẻ
đang bị quá
tải đấy kiểu dạng là tuy ở chưa quen
biết gì chưa thân mình lắm hai ngày mà m
gặp anh hai ngày như anh cảm thấy là Tôi
đang rất là gồng lúc đấy à Tôi không
nghĩ
là tôi
a Tôi không phải con người giả tạm nên
là để ra là tôi như nào chắc là mọi
người nhìn qua mọi người cũng có thể để
ý được chứ không tôi không giấu mình là
đang đang khó chịu hay đang như nào đấy
nhưng mà chắc là anh ấy cũng phải cũng
phải nói chung là người ta cũng qu tâm
với mình họ mới để ý được là mình đang
có vấn đề và anh ấy khuyên cũng như là
người cái kiểu hỗ trợ tôi lúc đấy Như
như thế nào
Ờ và chính từ từ giây phút ấy kiểu dạng
là tôi tìm được gọi là một người thầy
mới của đời
mình hôm qua tôi chưa Nhắn tin Cảm ơn
anh đấy quên mất Hôm qua tôi có rất rất
nhiều vấn đề nên là hôm qua gần như là
tôi chưa quên chưa Nhàn tin Cảm ơn các
người thấy của tôi
những người thầy mà đôi khi họ không
trực tiếp kiểu dạy mình ở trên trường
nhưng mà họ lại là những người mà thay
đổi cuộc đời mình nên là hôm qua thường
là ngày 20 tháng 11 thì tôi sẽ thường
nhắn tin thậm chí là gọi cho những người
thầy cũ của mình có thể thậm chí là họ
không hẳn họ quên mình đâu Nhưng mà cũng
chẳng để ý được đấy cơ họ
không Ví dụ là người Người Thầy ngoài
đời th đầu tiên của tôi là người dạy tôi
về
[âm nhạc]
lavel à Cũng có một bạn cũng vừa cảm ơn
tôi vì tôi dạy cho bạn đấy về larel đúng
không
xin chúc mừng bạn đấy Bây giờ công nhận
là công việc công việc lật trình Nói
chung bây giờ cũng cạnh tranh khá nhiều
rồi đặc biệt là ai Bây giờ sinh ra để
hỗi chất cho mình Nhưng mà thực ra đôi
khi nó cũng chính khiến cho việc công ty
đôi công ty không còn tuyển nhiều
nữa
à Có anh vẫn sẽ thường hay anh vẫn giữ
lại các video liv stream này nhưng mà
anh cũng đã cũng cân nhắc về việc là về
sau có khi phải không hẳn là phải xóa
nhưng mà nói chung là gọi như đây là
những video kỉ nghiệm thôi Anh cũng muốn
người khác có thể xem và xem được cho
đọc những cái bình luận này chẳng hạn
nhưng mà những cái video anh cứ xem lại
những video Hồi trước thì anh luôn bị
lấn cấm à Bởi vì không hẳn là mình đã
dạy sai đâu nhưng mà cảm thấy là mình
dạy chưa đủ bài bản chưa đủ gọi là gọi
là dạy thiếu hơn là dạy sai nên là anh
cũng cảm thấy là
ơ bây giờ đang để chế độ zê tư á Để qu
sinh ở public
ch thì nói chung là tôi cũng cân nhắc về
việc là vì sau cũng muốn sửa kiểu tôi sẽ
đăng thứ nhất là kiểu thì tôi sẽ làm
Tổng hợp lại video xong
rồi xong rồi à à Cập nhật lại giáo án
Chất Thứ thứ nói chong đăng lại hà video
mới video đấy sẽ gần như là giống mấy
cái video khóa học vậ chứ không phải là
video thuật livestream nữa nên là những
cái playlist cũ này này thc ra nó sẽ gọi
là như nó sẽ lỗi thời đúng không Nó dã
kiểu thực ra nó cũng có cái hay riêng ấy
của thì lúc đấy Lúc mình đang dạy một
cái tự nhiên nhất là sẽ chia sẻ những
cái nó cũng hay riêng giống như làở thời
đấy tôi từ chia sẻ mấy ông về tool
Facebook chẳng hạn đúng không Đấy mình
cái đấy nó cũng hay ho mà tôi nghĩ là
tại v cái đấy nhỏ nhỏ đấy lại là cái thứ
mình chia sẻ tâm sự với nhau thoải mái
giống như là hồn mà tôi vừa trêu mấy ông
n Ba chẳng hạn đấy thì nó tự nhiên mới
thoải mái
nó nó có gì đó kiểu dạng là không hẳn
như mà mình đang học đấy nó đỡ hơn còn
mấy cái video kia sẽ là mấy video nghiêm
túc kiểu Dạ là sẽ không không biết dùng
từ nghiêm túc hay không như Chắc chắn là
sẽ rất là chuyên nghiệp
đấy Kiểu
là sẽ rất là bài bài Tôi sẽ nhờ bên spum
để mà lên giảo án các thứ thứ tài liệu
các thứ Chuyên chỉ nên
là nên là nó sẽ theo một cái tông
khác chắc là mấy cái video này tôi vẫn
sẽ giữ lại nhưng tôi sẽ gỡ ở trong cái
playlist để mà Nếu giả sử có những bạn
nào muốn thuần làm để học tôi thì sẽ học
từ những cái pist chuyên nghiệp kia cò
những video này chắc là ừ n giữ lại tôi
tôi Thỉnh thảng tôi có xem lại nhá tôi
xem lại nhưng mà đương nhiên không thể
xem lại theo kiểu để thời gian mặc định
được bởi vì thế thì chắc là rất là nhiều
tiếng chắc là tôi sẽ kiểu dùng tua rồi
để chế độ nhanh Tôi cảm thấy là tôi đang
nói chậm ạ Nhưng mà khi mà nghe lại ở
chế độ nhanh ấ cũng thấy hay hay mà đỡ
Bình
hôm nay sẽ là một buổi tâm sự kiểu dạng
là sau một năm qua tôi đã rất nhiều lần
muốn livestream lại rồi từ hồi Tết này
từ hồi rất nhiều nhưng mà tôi khi mà tôi
muốn livestream lại như này tôi cảm thấy
là tôi phải tâm lý ổn định lại đã cái
việc làm mình phải có thực sự là dành
nhiều thời gian cho nó ví dụ là bây giờ
tôi xác định được là một tuần hai buổi
như này nghĩa là hai buổi đấy tô không
phải là hai buổi mỗi hai tiếng một tuần
đúng không ạ sẽ phải dành thời gian để
mà chuẩn bị cho nó nữa nên là sẽ và và
sẽ phải lâu dài chứ không phải tuần này
rảnh thì livestream tuần sau cũng rảnh
live không như thế được mình sẽ phải có
một sự cam kết lâu dài thì mình mới dám
là làm đúng không ạ thì à Thực ra bây
giờ cũng
xyên suốt được trong lòng mình bao nhiêu
lâu nữa cái vụ livestream thứ ba thứ năm
này vì tôi định sang năm chắc là sau Tết
tôi sẽ về bên FPT để dạy nếu mà dạy thì
chắc là sẽ dạy buổi tối thì cũng có thể
sẽ vướng vào dịch này Nói chung là tôi
sẽ sắp xếp lại V Tôi sẽ sắp xếp và sẽ
thông báo các bạn sau Nhưng
mà đầu tiên thì tôi nói lý do tại sao tự
nhiên tôi quyết định quay lại kiểu thứ
nhất là kiểu gì cũng sẽ định quay lại
nhưng mà tại sao lại chọn lại mất thời
gian này vì tự nhiên tôi nhớ lại
cái đầu tiên thì hơi xa xăm một tí là
tôi nhớ lại
cái dự án Tôi từng làm cho trường cũ cái
dự án đấy tôi tôi phải công nhận tôi rất
là tâm huyết cho nó Tuy là Ừ thì giao
diện cũng đi copy ở bên admin LTE xong
rồi tính năng thì
cũng tính năng thực ra rất là ổn nhưng
mà nhưng mà kiểu dạng là Ờ
mình mình tự một mình mình làm ấy không
biết test rồi có nhiều bấc vãi trưởng ấ
xong rồi cứ làm đến đâu sửa đến đấy Xong
rồi Vừ Hồi đấy là vừa học vừa làm hồi
đấy là tôi
Ờ nghỉ họ à Tôi ra trường tôi được mờ
lại dậy xong rồi tôi tự học larel luôn
Tôi tự ngồi mò larel với
Z thấy cái trang web trông cứ kiểu cứ
kiểu dạng
như đọc code nó hơi bị tạp nhan nói thật
là hơ bị tạp
Nhan nên là nhưng mà tính ra Nó là một
cái con Project rất là lớn rất là lớn ấy
và nó rất là tâm huyết của tôi hơn 2 năm
liền tôi dạy ở đấy tôi Ngày nào tôi cũng
được Cố MT
thì tôi cảm thấy là hồi đấy hồi mà làm
con Project đấy một con product của
riêng mình nên là tôi cảm thấy là tôi
đam mê
lắ Gần đây tôi đang bị mất đi cái đam mê
đấy
tôi có code ở trên công ty vẫn có công
ty tôi vẫn là produ cho bạn nào chưa
biết thì lập trình của mình sẽ có khái
niệm product và a product Tức là mình
làm dự làm cái sản phẩm của riêng mình
và mình kiếm lời từ nó giống như công ty
product tức là làm ra Ví dụ Có rất nhiều
công ty product bây giờ sử cứ cho
Facebook là một cái product của công ty
Meta đúng không Tập đoàn Meta thì thì họ
kiếm tiền từ đấy còn nh còn những công
ty ao xộc Tức là sao Thấy dộ giả sử như
bên FPT FPT người ta không nghĩ là ý
tưởng gì cả nhưng mà họ qu nhiều nhân
công nên là họ nhận các dự án bên ngoài
để mà làm sản phẩm hỗ trợ cho các bên
ngoài kia
riêng nhưng mà Đúng là nhân công của họ
rất nhiều nên họ nhận làm nó s bên ngoài
nhiều lắm thì làm a sộc nó sẽ có nhều
điểm và bởi vì nó không sản phẩm của
riêng mình nên mình sẽ ít đặc tâm và nó
hơn mình không thực sự là quan tâm việc
là nó có có trải nghiệm tốt cho người
dùng hay không vân vân đấy may mà từ
trước này tôi toàn làm product thôi bất
kỳ cái gì tôi chia sẻ t trước này vẫn là
product những cái kiểu rất là tâm huyết
của bản thân nh nên
là và trí nhớ của tôi khá là dị Tôi nhớ
được toàn bộ những cái Tôi đã từng code
kể cả những dòng code đầu tiên luôn Tôi
bây giờ tôi đọc lại cái git hack của tôi
h mà tôi chia sẻ tool Facebook Tôi vẫn
nhớ được à Tại sao lý do mình code đoạn
đấy rồi nó tệ như nào Ừ nhưng mình nhớ
được Lý do mình code cái đoạn đấy có
nhiều người không nhớ được đâ Nhu người
không hiểu tại sao mình nghĩ gì mình làm
cái đoạn đấy vây mấy ông mà xem lại kiểu
code đầu tiên của m ông m ông có nhớ
được Tại sao mình code là đấy không đấy
kểu thấy hỏi code này code của ai chẳng
hạ
Ừ ừ đấy thì cái vụ mà có một bạn Vừ nhắc
về
cái GS cl sinh trọ học
à th cái đấy cũng là một trong những cái
dự án mà tôi định rất là tâm hiết Gần
đây tôi không hẳn là có ý định
tôi Ừ tôi có ý định quay lại làm cái con
đấy Tôi sẽ ý định quay lại làm tiện ích
con đấy tiện ích trước xong rồi trang
web sau mỗi tội nó vẫn vấn đề nó hơi
nhạy cảm một tí thê bây giờ mình chuẩn
bị đi dậy đi dậy mà tự nhiên quay lại
làm cái
con nhắc đến kiểu lái sinh các thứ thứ
nhạy cảm cực đặc biệ mình có livestream
làm bụi đấy gấp đôi nhạy cảm
là mic có vẻ không tương thích với con m
này lắm nên mic nó không còn dọn trầm
Mấm đúng không thôi
thì không trầm Mấm thì có khi mấy ông
lại bước Vừ ngủ tôi nghe khá nhiều ông
bảo là nghe giọng tôi xong kiểu cứ đều
đều đều
nói về cái đam mê ấy Gần đây tôi có xem
không biết được là mấy ông có xem phim
Gia Đình Siêu Nhân Không cái giờ
inqu
giờ có dính có bị dính bản Quyệt khi mở
ngoài cái hành này lên không thì mấy ông
xem tập 1 nó mang nhiều ý nghĩa hơn rất
nhiều những phần hai phần ba thường hay
kiểu nó kiểu do phần lượt hành công làm
phần hai phần 3 thôi phần 1 đ là phần ý
nghĩa nhất ấy pH của Pixel thì càng
Pixel Chắc biết âm như nào t kèm tiếng
Anh không cả
thì thì phim của bên này thì có nhiều
niền ý nghĩa và nó là phim mật hình
nhưng mà lại phù hợp cho cả trẻ con và
người lớn đúng không Thì người lớn trẻ
con thì xem vẫn hay nhưng người lớn Xem
sẽ sẽ có suy nghĩ là sẽ kiểu Chiêm nhiệm
khác thì phần một nó nói về kiểu dạ
mà cái đoạn đầu ông Bốn là Siêu hnh Hùng
là kiểu Gánh được
cả gánh được rất nhiều thứ trên vai cả
gia đình trên vai chẳng ngh bóng chẳng
ngh đen đúng không Nhưng mà giờ về sau
kiểu khi mà ông không được làm siêu anh
hùng nữa thì mình mới nhìn thấy cảm giác
của một người đàn ông kiểu đang từ rất
là khỏe mạnh đang rất là kiểu đúng kiểu
là trụ cột của gia đình tự nhiên trở nên
rất là g bó t túng ở trong phim này thể
hiện rất rõ về kiểu cái gọi là nghệ
thuật nghệ thuật làm phim nghệ thuật
kiểu dạng là dùng những cái khung hình
kểu làm cho ông đấy ông ấy mọi người nhớ
là ông ấy đi quả con
xe
xe trông vò bó ngồi trong cái xe bé tí
ngồi trong cái văn phòng bé tí không
đúng không Đấy r V sao có xe kiểu nh này
đấy đấy kiểu dạng là xong rồi nó còn
mang hình vuông hình hộp th này tôi hồi
đấy Thực ra tôi cũng biết tôi để ý lại
qua phê phim người ta phân tích lại thôi
Em chỉ là kiểu ờ
ý tôi muốn nói ở đây là ông ấy không còn
tự nhiên thoải mái nữa ông không còn là
chính mình nữa ông ấy lúc nào cũng trong
tình trạng là
kểu không kiểu mất đi cái đàn ông của
mình mất đi cái tôi của B Hân đấy
Ờ tôi cảm thấy là kiểu thực ra hai giới
nói chung
thôi à Hai g Nói chung thì ai cũng có
cần cái sự cầu Tiến với kiểu dạng là
Hoài Bão hoài bão các thứ thứ nhưng tôi
cảm thấy là một thằng con trai đặc biệt
một thằng đàn ông kể Dạ
ngài nên có một cái đam mê gì đó nên có
một sự hài báo gì đó nhất định thì gần
đây thì tôi chứ không phải cứ cắm đầu đi
làm kiếm tiền coi như là mình sẽ thá đn
ông là chộ của đ không phải như thế Cò
đây tôi cảm thấy
là lâu lắm rồi tôi không không có đam mê
nhiệt huyết một cái gì đó
quay lại làm một cái sản phẩm gì đó của
riêng mình để mình lại đam mê lại nhiệt
hiết với nó kểu thế lúc đấy mình cảm
thấy mình tràn chế sức sống hơn rất
nhiều
Ờ đấy từ cái bộ phim này chúng ta m rút
ra được cái kiểu chết lý nhân sinh à chờ
thế hay mà thôi Gần đây tôi đọc à Không
hẳn đọc nữa như tôi gần đây tôi biết là
nghe nhiều hơn rồi Đang nghe cả Podcast
xong rồi
Ờ nói chung
là nói chung là được nhìn như người cá
nhìn hơn rồi hồi trước thì đúng là mình
nhìn mọi thứ nó cứ kểu hạn hẹp hơn
Xem các bạn hỏi gì
nhá sinh viên 54 mà chỉ biết thêm sửa
xóa kết nối database thì có ổn không
Ồ Thực ra là phải nói như nào mình không
quan tâm về tổi tác mình không quan tâm
về việc là em đang như nào đấy thậm chí
em học tránh lại cũng được
thân A thì các Anh thường an nói thế
Mình luôn so sánh mình với chính mình
trong quá khứ thôi Nếu mà em cảm thấy
thực ra là gọn như này anh cũng có cô
nói nữa Đó là kiểu Khi mà mình cảm thấy
cái gì đó không ổn thì nó là không ổn
thôi Em không cần phải hỏi lại là Liệu
có ổn không vì bản thân em cảm thấy
không ổn thì người ta bảo em là ổn thì
em có tin
không từ việc là em yêu đương mà em cảm
thấy không ngồn thì không quan tâm về
việc
Ờ có thấy ổn hay không vì tự em đánh giá
thôi Ờ tiếp theo
ơ mic tự nhiên to
á tôi vừa tắt cái tai nghe của tôi không
biết là thế là mới khiến nó to hơn không
B Ờ t nghe của tôi hết pin Ờ mấy ông
Nghe giọng có giống lại giọng cũ hồi
livestream cũ
tay nghe nà đây
nhỉ Ok
hết cả lên hóa ra là do cái này hơi đen
Ờ thì quay lại một tí đó là khi mà mình
không thấy ổn và cái gì đó bao gồm với
việc là mối quan hệ mình có ổn hay không
người yêu mình ổn hay không Mình học
ngày ngày ổn hay không Hay là Ờ mình mua
món đồ này ổn hay không Mỗi khi mà em Lã
lấn cấn về việc đấy Tốt nhất em không
nên làm gần như là gần đây có tôi có hỏi
một một bạn nữa là kiểu không biết là
mình hỏi cái này có tí Nhị quá hay không
Bạn ấy cũng nói tôi câu tương tự một khi
mà bạn đã lấn cấn về việc định hỏi cái
gì đó ấy tốt nhất bạn không nên hỏi bạn
không nên nói
đấy Đấy là một cái lời khuyên tôi thấy
cũng khá là Hiếu ích nghĩa là một khi mà
mình lấn cấn cái gì đó là bản thân mình
cũng thấy không ổn rồi nên là mình không
cần phải hỏi
nữa nhưng mà bây giờ để quay lại việc là
thế thế mà giả sử bây giờ không ổn thì
bây giờ mình làm như thế nào thì như tôi
vừa nói là không nên so sánh mình với
bản thân ai cả không phải thấy thằng
khác sinh viên năm nhất năm hai nó đi đi
làm được rồi Mình sinh viên năm tư hoặc
là thậm chí ở ra trường rồi Mình Chưa
kiếm được việc mình đừng nên so sánh thế
mình cứ so sánh mình với bản thân trong
quá khứ
thôi mình đâu Biết được hoàn cảnh của
đứa kia như th nào để mà mình đánh giá
là mình phải như thế nào so với nó mà
mình cứ so sánh mình chính mình trong
quá khứ là kiểu ví dụ là giả sử ha năm
ông học công nghệ thông tin rồi mà ông
vẫn dậm chân tại chỗ
thì đúng là ông nên xem lại là thực sự
là thứ nhất là ông đã đủ cố gắng hay
chưa Thứ hai là thực sự ông có hợp cái
ngành này không Bởi vì nếu mà ông cảm
thấy không ổn như thế thì vấn đề nguyên
nhân gốc dễ Nó phải từ đâu đúng
của của tai nghe không Bởi vì bởi vì tôi
vừa nãy tôi chỉnh thì là mic của của cái
này đấy nhưng mà Ừ nói chung Tôi không
rõ lắm
Ờ nhưng mà th quay quay lại cái kia thì
theo tôi thì
mình cố gắng hết sức thì mình sẽ không
có gì phải ấn hận cả trong mọi vấn đề
luôn Tôi không nói về mỗi lập trình hay
sự nghiệp
à Tôi sẽ chỉ ân hận và lấn cấn khi mà về
sau sẽ mình không cố hết sức mình không
TH thử bây giờ mình thử mình cố hết sức
rồi thì mình chẳng ấn hận gì cả kể cả kể
cả hồi trước giả sử là tôi có chừa đại
học nó tôi không hề ấn hận hay kiểu nuối
tiếc gì cả vì tôi cảm thấy tôi cố gắng
hết sức rồi mình năng lực mình chỉ đến
thế thôi thì việc gì mình phải ấn hận
đấy cũng như việc tàn gái cũng chẳng hạn
ông tàn gái ông thử hết mọi chường hợp
ông kiểu cũng cố gắng trong m quan đệ
đấy rồi mà bạn ấy không chấp nhận ông
thì chỉn giả là nó không thì bạn ấy
không phù hợp ông ông ông nên từ bỏ đúng
không đươ nhiên là mình cũng phải biết
được là cái giới hạn để đến lúc nào mình
nên từ bỏ Nói chung là
ờ biết được khả năng của mình đến đâu và
biết được giới hạn
là là cái rất là quan trọng ông càng
biết được cái đấy sớm thì ông càng làm
được nhiều
chắc chắn là Ông chẳng làm được cái gì
cả nhưng mà ông thử ông ông cố gắng hít
sức ông phải biết điểm dừng ông phải
biết giới hạn đến đâu đừng có cố quá thì
về sau gọi
nhở nó sẽ bị kiểu dạng cố quá Nếu kéo
một cái thứ không thuộc về mình thì cũng
không ổn đúng
chung trong mọi vấn đề kể không phải mỗi
sự nghiệp không phải mỗi quan hệ mối
quan hệ đúng không Nghĩa Nói chung thế
mình mình có tư tưởng chung như thế cho
mọi thứ trong cuộc sống cũng ổn
mà thầy mới mua má ạ Không cái này là
công ty cấp thực ra chuẩn là tôi cũng
không muốn Đương nhiên Công ty thì vẫn
cho phép thôi nhưng mà nhưng mà Đúng là
tôi không muốn dùng
máy của công ty để làm bất kỳ cái việc
gì cá nhân bao gồm việc cài game nhưng
gần đây tôi cũng lỡ cài rồi xin lỗi công
ty
à Tôi nghĩ là sang năm tôi
sẽ được thưởng tết này các thứ các thứ
có tiền thì sẽ sắm hẳn một con m mới tại
sao lại là m thì nói qua về ma thì
ờ hồi trước tôi là người rất
là kiểu anti à r khó chịu Má mác nhá Còn
đồ Apple nó khác tôi thì đương nhiên tôi
cũng ghé fan Apple nhưng mà tôi vẫn từng
dùng iPhone và tôi cũng thấy là nó có
những điểm lợi của nó mình là dân công
nghệ mình không thể kiểu kỳ thị các thứ
một cách kiểu dạng là tiêu cực được mình
vẫn phải thử mình vẫn phải trải nghiệm
để mình có góp nhiều góp nhìn nhưng hồi
trước thì đúng là tôi vẫn kỳ thị ra mặt
m thật bởi vì Điền hình là mấy đứa sinh
viên của tôi bọn nó mà dùng m thì tôi
không Tôi lại quen dùng Win nên là tôi
Thứ nhất là khó kết nối được sang máy nó
mỗi khi mà hỗ trợ cái gì gì đó cái việc
là nó dùng m xong rồi nó không biết dùng
ấy Nó cứ hỏi tôi những cái rất là cơ bản
xong rồi Kiểu m mò kiểu kiểu mở thư mục
lên ở đâu các thứ thứ kiểu máy của em mà
em phải biết điều đấy bảo anh cách mở
thư mục nên là hồi ấy tôi rất khó chịu
khi sinh viên mình kiểu mang mác đi học
kiểu Bởi
vì bởi vì nếu thế Ở trường có máy nhá
Tại sao không dùng máy trường em phải
làm quen với
việc
em phải làm quen với các bạn kiểu dùng
chung dùng chung với các bạn để mà khi
mà dạy thống nhất ấy chứ Tôi đang dạy
cho mấy ông dùng Win một kiểu thôi lại
phải chuyển qua dạy cho mấy ông m một
kiểu trong khi đó tôi còn chưa dùng m
bao giờ nó bị cấn ấy có nhiều trường
nhiều trường Hồi trước tôi còn biết được
cấm cho sinh viên mang laptop riêng cá
nhân đi cơ trường tôi vẫn tương đối
thoải mái cho phép đấy nhưng mà chính vì
thoải mái thế th mờ ông ví dụ điển hình
chính vì mấy kiểu vụ như thế nhá Tôi dạy
sang buổi thứ ba rồi mấy ông dùng M vẫn
còn đang ngồi trợt vật cài đặt ở buổi
thứ nhất nên Hồi đấy tôi khá là kiểu
tiêu cực với mấy ông má xong
rồi nhưng mà đương nhiên là sau này ví
dụ bây giờ công việc này tôi cảm thấy là
Win nó làm mọi tác vụ ở trên máy win có
vẻ đang bị chậm rồi nên là tôi chuyển
qua MT Tôi dùng nói chung là tôi không
hẳn là kỳ thị một cách kiểu tiêu tiêu
cực cực đoan đế nỗi là kiểu kiểu
Thế ông kia vừa gạo tôi cài vs code đúng
không không không không riêng vs code
của ông thì tôi có một chương rất dài về
mấy cái đấy thứ nhất là may là tôi vẫn
đang dùng được meu để mà có thể dùng
miễn phí được pp Storm P và máy tôi dùng
p Storm chạy ngon không bị giật lag gì
cả cũng không trở ngại vộ đấy xong rồi
Tiếp theo
là là
à Sếp của tôi Anh Bình vừa nãy thì đang
dùng vs code và Chính vì vs code nó kiểu
Chắc là anh ấy không mở lên thôi vì do
gì đấy đôi khi là có những cái kiểu đoạn
code của anh đấy kiểu đáng ã nó có thể
ngắn gọn hơn hoặc là nó chỉ thậm chí là
đôi khi nó còn sai chẳng hạn bởi vì
thằng pp st tôi gợi ý đỏ lòm đoạn đấy
luôn nhưng mà vs code của anh đấy thì
không gợ ý đoạn đấy gì cả điển hình là
lỗi chính tải chẳng hạn nói chung là có
thể mở lên được Tôi nhớ là hình như có
thể mở lên được vài cái cà plugin vào
chắc nó cũng hỗ trợ nhiều đấy nhưng
mà nhưng mà ông hiểu ý tôi không nghĩa
là anh đấy cài V code tôi cài pp stone
nên thành ra tôi luôn debug được code
của anh đấy vì bản chất là hai chúng ta
dùng hai cái phần mềm khác nhau nên là
anh đấy không nhìn được tức cả không có
nghĩa là tôi không nhìn được đấy nghĩa
là hai người tôi cũng thường hay nói thầ
với anh Bình anh Bình xếp tôi thì anh ấy
thường hay và kiểu anh nhiều lúc thấy
chú kiểu tư duy kiểu gì ý sa V tôi nói
là anh đấy là kiểu Chính vì em tư duy
khác anh nên là em sẽ nhìn ra được vấn
đề của anh và anh cũng sẽ nhìn ra được
vấn đề của em nếu hai người mà tư duy
giống hệt nhau COD giống hệt nhau thì
nếu mà có Có mà sinh ra bấc thì chắc là
chẳng ai nhìn ra được Cái Bấc của nhau
tư duy giống hệt nhau mà đúng không
Chúng ta phải tư duy khác nhau thì chúng
ta mới nhìn đánh giá được theo góc độ
khác đúng không
đâu anh á Không ý tôi chắc là chắc là ý
tôi không phải đam mê mãi một thứ nhưng
mà mình
cần mình sống thì mình nên Thứ nhất là
mình phải có một tí đam mê động lực gì
gì đó Làm gì đó thứ hai là
Nói gì quên mất
rồi đam mê
Ừ tự nhiên đang nói đang đị nói câu gì
quên mất rồi h tạm bỏ qua khi nhớ lại
nói tiếp tôi Thỉnh thảng
kiểu nghĩ loạn lên lắm
2 N3 mà làm được cái này cái kia nhiều
khi tự ti với kiến thức ở trường dạy
Ờ Anh bảo rồi không nên so sánh tự ti
với ai
cả ai cũng
sẽ có một cái thế mạnh gì đó có ưu và có
nhược gì đó nhược của tôi chẳng hạn
Nhược tôi nói nhiều này Nhược tôi là
trên tay kiểu yếu đuối này không làm
được việc nặng vân vân tôi khắc phục nó
bằng cái là tôi sẽ làm những công việc
nó nhiều và tôi làm không việc công việc
không không liên quan đến chân tay chẳng
hạn thế mình biết được cái ưu và cái
nhược của mình xong rồi ạ thí dụ tôi ưu
nữa là hồi trước tôi ngồi được Cắm máy
tính kiểu ngồi chơi game được cả ngày
chẳng hạn tôi chuyển qua làm những công
việc liên quan ngồi máy tính thôi tôi
làm được Tôi sẽ không làm được cái việc
khác kiểu thế Ờ ông càng xác định được
mình là ai trả lời được những cái câu
hỏi Đợi mình là ai mình thế mạnh của
mình và ưu nhược của mình như th nào thì
thì ông sẽ biết là ông sẽ phải làm gì
tiếp
h ông kia làm công nhân vẫn xem tôi á
thì thế chắc chắn là ông ngồi xem tôi
một là đợi tôi chia sẻ 300 bài codt
thiếu nhi để đổi đời hai là ngồi xem tôi
chém gió rồi chứ không ngồi xem tôi codt
sao được
mình cũng antim max nhưng cũng phải mua
m để dùng Ừ thì th ra thì tôi thấy thứ
nhất là ít nhất là nó gọn nhẹ hơn cái
con máy chạm hồi trước tôi mua tôi từng
Hình như tôi từng B phố các anh em có
nghe về vụ buff phố con máy chạm V đeo
cũ của tôi rồi mang Tứ máy chạm nhưng mà
nhanh tã nhanh tệ các th thứ thì tôi
thấy công nhận là m nó ổn định thật Nên
là chắc là hiện tại thì vẫn sẽ dùng và
sẽ vẫn sẽ mua
và tôi sẽ tôi thấy cái hay ở điểm đó là
mình ở Dân công nghệ mình cũng hơi tiêu
hoang một tí V việc là mình sẽ thỉnh
thoảng muốn nâng cấp cái công nghệ nâng
cấp đồ công nghệ của mình gi thấy là ít
nhất là mấy cái đồ kiểu mua m này các
thứ thứ nó có hỗ trợ thu cũ đổi mới
thỉnh thoảng lên đời nó hay kiểu
Tôi nhớ p stone bản chất nó cũng chứa
luôn cả webstorm nên là thực ra vẫn thể
vào xem f
được chỉ vài lệnh git cơ bản đi úi giồi
ôi Bây giờ ông không bảo tôi lệnh git
Chắc chắn là sẽ có người vào đây bó phố
tôi là kiểu tôi biết gì về lệnh git đâu
cứ thứ thứ tôi đến bây giờ tôi vẫn đang
Trung Thành với cái git Hub desktop đây
này
Đấy Tôi vẫn chỉ dùng những thao tác cơ
bản kiểu kéo về đẩy lên Xong rồi mớt Ờ
fix Conflict các thứ trông bị cứ bị
nghiệp dư á Ừ không Quick Conflict tôi
mới thấy là ông nào cũng như nhau hết
chẳng có ông nào gọi là trông chuyên
nghiệp cả kể cả dùng bất kỳ cái tool nào
hỗ trợ thì thì bản chất là mình vẫn hiểu
được phải hiểu được là đoạn code đấy như
nào nên là không không cần tự tin
đâu nay anh có làm gì ngoài P Không anh
Ờ tôi thực ra là tươ nhiên là tôi vốn
trước là tôi vẫn full stack là tôi vẫn
làm được cả Finance Cho dù là làm CS của
tôi khá là tệ CS nên là tôi không làm
nhiều về giao diện r Script thì tôi
không đào sâu Nói chung là tôi may công
ty cũng tạo điều kiện là tôi được làm
backen nhiều hơn Tôi thường ví dụ bây
giờ công việc của tôi vẫn thường là tập
trung làm tối ưu này Hôm trước Vừ làm
tối ưu phần thanh toán chẳng ạn nghĩa
tôi làm việc với api làm việcc với
database rất là nhiều
và tôi cũng muốn định hướng về sau tôi
vẫn H vọng là sẽ được động sang bên
database architect đấy Kiểu thế nghĩa
tôi vẫn muốn làm về SQL rất là nhiều như
các bạn không để ý Thực ra tôi tâm huyết
nhất vẫn là cái playlist SQL vì tôi khá
đam mê về cái SQL
không dùng cái đấy đâu các
bạn có thể lên trang lên trang chủ xem
rồi cảm thấy cái gì hay hay thì lấy về
thc ra tôi dùng chắc là tôi dùng mỗi p
stor nữ cả copilot
dạy tiếp mấy khóa chưa hoàn thiện á Thực
ra là nó mình mình nhớ là chỉ có mỗi cái
hai cái khóa chưa hoàn thiện một cái là
làm cái cũng tương đối là làm cái gì nhở
Ờ đăng cái CV à và còn một cái gì nữa
nhở xem
đây đồ án web mua giới Ơ có đồ án học
viện à mình có làm cả đồ án học viện
ồ
uây
mình hai buổi
buổi từ bao giờ rồi
năm
mình có làm vụ này
đang phải thắc mắc tại sao tôi lại làm
vụ này vì tính ra là cái này nó dài phết
đấy
Ừ hình như hồi này tôi làm là tôi làm để
demo cho mấy ông kiểu làm tính năng kiểu
làm trang web học viện thôi chứ chứ tôi
mà làm cái Làm
hẳn tôi mà làm hẳn cái làm lại hẳn cái
trang kiểu các thứ thứ thì thứ nhất là
mấy ông sẽ dễ ôm về để đem bán này Thực
ra là tôi hơi ngại vụ đấy Tôi không ngại
chia sẻ nhưng tôi không thích kiểu ai đó
lợi dụng các thứ thứ thế hoặc là không
phải đem bán nhưng nói chung là họ mà
đem về kiểu nó cũng không tốt Tôi vẫn
muốn là mấy ông vẫn tự phân tích tự nghĩ
hơn tôi dạy ông bản chất là dạy lập
trình C ở rèn tư duy chứ không phải dạy
dạy mỗi code
à Nhưng mà đúng Ừ nó to đấy được khi nào
tôi nhưng mà tôi cũng không ý định là
tôi sẽ làm lại hẳn cái đấy mà tôi tôi
chắc là về sau tôi like code thì chắc là
làm tiện ích hoặc làm trang web khác đấy
vẫn là trong web gái sinh kia nhưng mà
chắc là tôi sẽ phải che tên đi cái việc
là tôi sẽ phải thay ảnh khác đi cho nó
đỡ nhạy
đi h Nhìn mấy cái comit hơi bị Kiểu cái
thằng g Hub desktop thỉnh thoảng để xuất
ra
cái gợi ý commit các thứ thứ nhưng mà
anh ghi commit trông chuẩn mà em xem bên
B này anh ghi commit trông quá xị luôn
xem một cái demo nha này thấy không
Update CH C customer email nằm ở trong
file nào đấy đầy đủ trông rõ ràng mà
chẳng qua là bên fanan thì anh không
muốn con mid kiểu nói chung là không hơi
vô tâm ở bên
làm lại kinh khủng bởi vì cái vụ mvc đấy
nó vẫn chỉ rất hết sức cơ bản nên là để
mấy ông mà bắt trước làm cái đấy để làm
mvcc thuần thì sẽ không làm được thì
chắc là tôi vẫn muốn nói chung là ờ bên
SQL của tôi tôi vẫn thấy tôi dạy vững
nhất tôi cảm thấy chẳng cần phải chỉnh
sửa gì bên hồi dạy SQL cả Còn mấy bên
khác Nói chung thì tôi vẫn muốn là phải
phải đập đi làm lại để mà làm nó bài bản
hơn chia sẻ về nghề data Engineer được
không Tôi chưa làm Bên mảng đấy rồi
không biết chia sẻ như nào Nhưng mà chắc
chắn ông phải học SQL đấy nên ông học
qua ex của tôi
đi làm sao để copy table từ database này
sang database
khác copy à Thực ra tôi thường biết cái
vụ là select
Insert select Insert của SQL Nhưng mà
cái này nó chỉ áp dụng cho trong mục
cùng database thôi tôi chưa từng thấy vụ
khác database bao giờ này Insert into
xong rồi select form table như này là là
coi như là sẽ sao chép một cái bảng này
xong bảng tạo hành một bảng mới xong rồi
copy dữ liệu toàn bộ từ sang bên kia hay
phết còn vụ kia thì chắc là cũng phải
làm bằng code thôi
SQL theo kiểu hướng đối tượng ủi không
biết vụ này
luôn Đúng rồi SQL bây giờ gần như là
ngôn ngữ lập trình rồi vòng lập biến các
thứ còn hướng đối tượng ạ anh có dạy
viết api không
Ừ Dạy viết thì chẳng biết dùng từ như
nào Nhưng mà tôi từng chỉ mấy ông biết
qua api cơ bản là gì rồi còn để mà dạy
viết thì nghe Giống như kiểu dạy Ông
viết Grap QL hơn thì nó mới gọi là một
cái gì đó rất là chuyên nghiệp thì đúng
là tôi chưa làm vụ đấy để mà để mà dạy
học tốt SQL thì có những công việc gì
phù hợp ạ Giống như bạn vừa nói ở trên
là data Engineer không nhá hoặc là bia
cũng được hoặc là thậm chí test tester
Bây giờ tôi thấy tester mà biết về SQL
xong rồi biết cũng dùng kiểu pman đả Mảo
đủ
Ờ đây là game cuộc sống
à Nãy giờ đang tâm sự tuổi hồng
mà anh ơi sinh viên năm nhất ngành Công
nghệ thông tin bây giờ đang phân vân Có
nên học thiết kế vi mạch bàn dẫn hay vẫn
học phần mềm sẽ tốt hơn trong tương lai
bây giờ để mà tôi tư vấn chuyển sinh ấy
Tôi chẳng biết khuyên các bạn cái gì bây
giờ tôi chỉ biết được là ngành I bây giờ
rất là rộng không phải mỗi về công nghệ
ông tin ông học kể cả Bây giờ ông học
lập trình Nhưng mà ông thích nhảy sang
kiểu
khác miễn là vẫn trong ng t vẫn có thể
được thậm chí là học lập trình xong làm
ba học lập trình xong làm tester học
trình xong làm data Engineer vừa nãy hay
n thứ có miễn là ông có kiến thức cơ bản
về lập trình để mà có tư duy và biết một
tí ngôn ngữ để được biết được cách vận
hành của một cái phần mềm à hoàn toàn ổn
Còn bây giờ để ông nhảy sang Còn mấy cái
ngành kia thì thực ra là tôi không học
ngành đấy nên là tôi không biết khuyên
mấy ông như th nào nhưng mà tôi chỉ biết
được là it bây giờ rộng lắm nhiều lắm
Thậm chí gần đây Ai n mới sinh ra đúng
không Thì mình lại có thêm nghề mới là
nghề trên cho ai là kiểu để mà xác thực
xem là ai đấy là đang trả đời đúng hay
sai và mình trên ling thêm cho nó ấy
nghĩa là tuy là ai Chí là thầy kiểu cũng
cướp việc nhiều người Nhưng bồ lại nó
tạo ra công việc mới chẳng hạn nên
là tôi cảm thấy là it bây giờ cũng vẫn
rộng vẫn tiềm
trước kiến thức của mình hồi đấy Đúng là
thực ra là hồi đấy mình
Ờ mình phải rèn mấy cái đấy rèn mấy kiến
thức cơ bản đấy phải thậm chí chuyên sâu
đấy để mình đi dậy còn à Về sau thì mình
bổ sung thì chắc là qua những dự án thực
tế mình kiểu va chạm có rất nhiều bảng
lớn này xong rồi Kiểu những câu truy vấn
kiểu phức tạp này hối trước là tôi còn
phải làm cả cái vụ là kiểu à Viết một
câu ch vấn không quan tâm câu này dài
bao nhiêu miễn là bắt buộc phải một câu
Để nó chạy được trong cái A một cái phần
mềm Java thì nó sinh ra cái file pdf để
in a tổng điểm của tất cả sinh viên
chẳng hạn những sinh viên mà đạt đủ yêu
cầu ấy ô Hồi đấy câu truy vấn của tôi
hơn 200 dòng luôn kiểu thế để mà sinh ra
một cái bảng xong rồi bảng đấy có chứa
đầy đủ C điểm các thứ thứ vân vân kiểu
mình bị ép vào những cái bài toán rất là
thực tế nên là thành ra cái trình SQL nó
lên thôi Còn bây giờ nếu mà mình muốn
thực tập trước trải nghiệm Trước thì có
thể lên hacker rank nhưng mà hacker rank
tôi từng thấy có vài cái nó cũng dĩ lắm
Tôi cũng chưa áp dụng bao giờ nên là nên
là mình cũng phải gọi như là it bây giờ
thực ra là học ở rất nhiều nơi quan
trọng là mấy ông cũng phải học cách chọn
lọc một tí không thì học trên đấy xong
cũng bị quá
chức năng đi anh ý ông là trang web như
nào nhỉ trang web cụ thể hơn một tí
đâu hả enter cho password to install
Software update tôi có update cái gì đâu
Tự nhiên install hack à có nà đang hack
tôi đúng không mình để lộ ky ở đâu à th
cái đấy kệ đi em ạ Chấp Nhận Thôi dùng
cái kia tiện
op tôi dạy trên à Tôi dạy ở trên đây so
với trên trường nó sẽ bị thiếu rất là
nhiều bởi vì trên trên trường đôi khi là
thường ấy dạy chuẩn của Java hơn nên là
kiểu nó sẽ kiểu chặt chẽ hơn ấy pp về cơ
bản tôi thấy là thực ra nó cũng còn kiểu
không chặt chẽ không rõ ràng rất nhiều
cái lắm và Hồi đấy tôi dạy Cái đấy chỉ
cho các bạn kiểu giới thiệu qua các bạn
hình dung V MC thôi các bạn mà học theo
thì các bạn không làm được cái gì đâu
Nói thẳng như thế vì nó chưa đủ mà cái
đấy tôi dạy qua thế để tôi nhảy sang bên
Framework là cái thế mạnh của tôi nhiều
hơn nên thành ra là nếu mà các bạn mà
chỉ dừng ở cái ngưỡng học mvc xong thì
các bạn đúng là các bạn sẽ bị chơi vơi
thật nên là tôi mới cảm thấy là cái đoạn
đấy tôi phải đập đi HM lại nhưng mà để
mà dạy kỹ thì nó cũng khá là đau đầu tôi
phải dùng tử đau đầu vì bản thân tôi bây
giờ tôi còn phải đang học lại về Cái
design pattern anh à xếp Tôi cũng đang
phải kiểu hướng dẫn anh em lại mấy vụ
đấy nghĩa là bản thân là MC tiếng Tôi tự
nhận tôi cũng là xio rồi kiểu code lâu
rồi mà cũng làm được rất nhiều thứ rồi
nhưng mà về design button Nói chung của
anh em ở công ty tôi thực ra vẫn còn
chưa đủ chuyên nghiệp đặc biệt về op
chẳng hạn thế nên là nghĩa là mấy ông sẽ
thấy là đôi khi code mấy ông đủ tối ưu
ngon xịn rồi chạy được rồi làm được
những cái chức năng khó rồi nhưng mà
code vẫn chưa đủ tốt đủ chuyên
nghiệp nên là cái này nó cứ bị rộng ấy
rất là rộng để mà dạy một cái gì đó
và cái này còn phải tùy theo môi trường
của Tùy từng công ty nữa thành ra là
cũng khó dậy rồi lắm cái này tôi nghĩ là
mấy ông phải chấp nhận là bổ sung là đọc
thêm sách hoặc là hoặc là giống như Gần
đây tôi chuẩn bị phải đăng ký khóa học
để học thêm chẳng hạn chứ Học qua mạng
cái việc là không thực hành nhiều ấy thì
khó để mà tiếp thu được mấy cái đấy lắm
Bởi vì nếu mà tôi dạy xong thì mấy ông
đã có kinh nghiệm thực tế để mấy ông làm
đâu mấy ông sẽ kiểu thắc mắc là ôi tự
nhiên Kiểu cái đoạn đấy có đoạn chức
năng bé tí anh cũng vẽ ra tận mấy chục
file lại chia nhỏ nó làm gì kiểu mấy ông
sẽ không thực sự hiểu được là lợi ích
của mấy cái việc đấy để làm gì ý hiểu
không m ông phải trải nghiệm Chán ông
phải vào những cái dự án kiểu to vãi
trường ông mới thấy là Ừ cái việc chiên
nhỏ đấy ra nó có lý do của nó cả đấy nó
nó phải như thế nữa
cơ nên là đôi khi là cái cái việc tôi
dạy như thế Tôi dạy một cách sơ xài như
thế phải dùng từ sơ xài
cũng có lý do cả để cho mấy ông kiểu Ừ
Mấy ông đang non mà Thì mấy ông chỉ cần
code cơ bản như thế đủ rồi gọi là chong
nó chạy được là được rồi sao vì sau kiểu
khi mà vào những cái dự án lớn thì mấy
ông sẽ thấy là ừ code này tồi thật thì
mấy ông mới nhận ra được mình tồi chỗ
nào để mấy ông đập đi làm lại theo cái
kiểu chuyên nghiệp hơn chứ là lúc đầu
học v cái chuyên nghiệp ông sẽ chỉ thấy
nó vừa khó nó vừa khô khan nó vừa kiểu
ông sẽ cảm thấy tự bản thân ông cảm thấy
nó không thực tế nó giống như kiểu ông
học Toàn cao cấp các thứ các thứ ông lúc
đầu ông sẽ thấy kiểu nó chẳng áp dụng
thực tế cả đấy nhưng về sau mới nhận ra
được Ừ nó rèn cho mình tư duy đấy th nó
nó nó kiểu thế
bend ấy mình sẽ đập đi
làm lại cái này khác nhiều chắc chỉ giữ
lại bên SQL
tập trung chỉ làm mỗi SQL SQL đảm bảo
xịn hơn mấy ông de bình thường Nhiều mấy
ông de bình thường Mới có khi kiểu m câu
select cũng kiểu select bừa ấy cũng
không biết subquery cũng không biết Joy
sub cũng kiểu chạy hết trong chạy hết
trong một câu nó đôi khi bị nặng
nhưng mà tôi cũng chưa động bao giờ
không biết web 3 là gì Cho dù tôi làm
full stack về
Ừ kỹ năng do code kém kỹ năng code và
đọc tài liệu xài tool Ừ để nói như nhở
nếu mà ông làm về công nghệ thông tin ấy
Thực ra là ông chỉ cần tiếp xúc nó kiểu
đọc tài liệu như như này đủ nhiều là ông
sẽ cảm thấy là ừ nó hiểu n ná gì đấy ví
dụ thậ sự tôi đọc qua ở đây tôi đọc lướt
nhiều nên là tôi không để ý mấy cái chữ
kiểu statement require này các thứ thứ
thôi Chẳng biết dịch cái từ này nó ra là
gì chẳng hạn Ờ nói chung là hiểu một
cách tương đối một vài chữ trong này
thôi Nhưng mà bây giờ có a hỗ trợ
chbt hỗ trợ các thứ dịch rồi mà ông ông
dùng chity nhiều vào xong rồi bảo nó
explain ông đủ thứ là được không n ví dụ
copy đoạn này
vào dịch và giải
thận các thứ thứ không thì bắt giải
thích kỹ hơn đi Chẳng hạn như này này À
đấy nó có giải thích như này tôi bây giờ
tôi tận dụng chat dbt Nhiều kinh khủng
luôn tiện rất nhiều Tôi định ngày hôm
sau nói chung là những cái buổi sau tôi
dạy lại live code ấy tôi sẽ mở tra DVD
ngay bên cạnh thì tôi sẽ dùng nó liên
tục mấy ông sẽ thấy Ui kiểu tận dụng nó
triệt để như nào kiểu ví dụ là tôi
thường hay tôi thường hay chat và nó Tôi
sẽ yêu cầu nó làm một cái kiểu làm một
tính năng ABC x yz thôi tôi yêu rồi yêu
cầu Nó là kiểu thực ra Kết quả nó phải
như thế này này để nó sẽ viết lại cái
đoạn code đấy sao cho Kết quả nó khớp
với cái kết quả của
tôi nghĩa là tiếng Anh chỉ cần đủ đọp
tài
liệu và code Thực ra là gần đây anh Bình
anh Bình cũng hơi kém với tiếng anh tí
so với tôi Anh ấy toàn nói kiểu mình
người Việt với nhau mà kiểu
ghi thứ nhất là ghi com ghi kiểu chú
thích code comment của anh đấy ghi bằng
tiếng Việt luôn đấy còn code code Anh ấy
đặt tên biến cả hàm tươ nhiên bng tiếng
An Rồi nhên thỉnh thoảng sai chính đả s
ở lại dùng dùng Ờ kiểu một là dùng cái
tiện ích để sử sửa kiểu bắt lỗi chính tả
hai kiểu đấy copy và CHT gần đây Tôi
cũng thường ngay kiểu vào CHT để nói là
kiểu đấy tôi đây I want to Cre function
to separate cái gì gì đó chẳng
hạn coma
s Z function chẳng
hạn có thể nói tiếng Anh có thể không
chuẩn nó lắm nhưng mà nó hiểu mà Đấy nó
sẽ gửi ý những cái tên của function mình
nên đặt nó là gì này Đấy Xong ông thấy
tên nào ông thấy cái tên nào mà ông hiểu
thì ông phải copy vào nhá Đừng thấy mấy
cái tên kiểu ngầu ngầu như này ông copy
vào nhá kiểu đụng đồng nghiệp Ông chẳng
hiểu cái dis disle Nó là cái gì đâu
chẳng hạn th ông cũng không hiểu đúng
không hiểu ông đừng copy vào ví dụ là
separate này device này Ừ ông có phải
hiểu thì ông copy vào
phải ai nó không đủ rõ nghĩa trong hoàn
cảnh đấy thì không ổn đâu ông dùng ai
vào thì nó mới kiểu hiểu được cái cái
trong cái hoàn cảnh đấy trong tình huống
đấy thì nên dịch như nào thì nó hợp lý
hơn
chứ
Nhưng mà anh sẽ chắc là sẽ tắt nó về sau
nếu mà khi anh đăng cái mấy cái mới thì
anh sẽ ẩn nó khỏi cái nói chung gần như
xóa cái play playlist thôi chứ không
phải xóa video để anh sẽ đăng Hàn
playlist mới để những cái bạn mới có thể
vào xem được hoặc anh phải đánh dấu gì
gì đó thì cho các bạn mới kiểu các bạn
đấy sẽ quan tâm những cái video chuyên
nghiệp hơn còn những cái video cũ Thực
ra nó nó như nào nhỉ nó vẫn có cái tôi
vẫn cảm thấy là kiểu Ừ chắc là mình có
con mới nưới cũ à kểu
managing mon blw chan
Mode standard đ hay là Monitor nhỉ cái
này cái nào ngon hơn
SQL với cơ sở dữ liệu triệu râ thì cái
nào ngon hơn à Gần đây anh tôi có hỏi
câu đấy thức ra nó rơi vào những cái bài
toán Ờ như nào
nhỉ Gần đây tôi có hỏi một anh là thực
ra nó là là câu tương tự này đó là dùng
join bình thường hay dùng sub join à
Chính xác là join với sub table thì cái
nào nó ổn hơn Nghĩa là nghĩa là tôi tách
ra ông ông biết cái kiểu join như này
không Tôi thử gõ cho ông một ví dụ nhá
Đợi tí Đợi tí thôi chết lộ hết rồi thôi
th C nhìn th này mấy không Nhìn tên mà m
không đoán được Sao được Ờ để xem
xếp tôi biết xếp tôi giết
thôi chắc mở tạm ở trên sa tch
chịu ờ sound form TH
a chẳng hạn đây A
đi join với mấy ông biết cái này
một cái g gì đó thôi hoặc sao cũng được
Nhưng mà nên là ít thôi thì nó hợp lý
hơn ví dụ là name chẳng ạ form b on b
chid bằng a ch bid chẳng hạn như này thì
thì cái này là cái này
là
không Cái này có thể thêm như này rất là
hay này qu theo à deate bằng cái gì đó
đi như thế này một cái gì gì đó thì tôi
gần đây tôi bảo là cái vụ này nó
sẽ tốt
hơn tốt hơn việc kiểu join bình thường
không cái đoạn này tức là sao nghĩa bản
thân bản thân cái này nó là tôi đã gần
như là có một cái bảng mới là subtable
mà không hoàn toàn là bảng B nữa mà bản
thân là cái đoạn này que que một tí điều
kiện rồi ông hình dung không qu một tí
điều kiện rồi nên là cái này nó sẽ ví dụ
bảng B triệu bản ghi bản A Triệu bản ghi
Nhưng mà việc triệu rồii 1 triệu chắc vỡ
mồm đúng không Thì bây giờ cái bảng này
có que thêm một vài đều kiện rồi nó sẽ
đỡ hơn nên là luôn Joi bảng bé với một
cái bảng bé nữa như kiểu như này nó đỡ
hơn nhưng anh ấy bảo là làm thế này
nhược điểm bởi vì làm này không biết
được Lúc ấy tôi bảo làm này tôi thấy nó
chạy nhanh hơn rồi anh ấy bảo làm thế
thì chỉ có thể là do là lúc đầu cái việc
on này của An bị sai nó có thể không
đánh Index hay gì gì đó đại khái chứ làm
thế này nó còn làm tốn cả thêm tài
nguyên bởi vì làm như này nó sẽ tạo thê
một cái alias một cái tem tem table
là một bảng tạm nên là nó sẽ tốn bộ nhớ
hơn đấy thực tế là khi mà Mấy ông dùng
explain của thằng SQL ấy nó sẽ thường
nhắc đến cả về khái niệm cost cost ở đây
là kiểu về là cost dịch ra là kiểu cái
giá phải trả kiểu kiểu thế đúng không
Thì nó sẽ có memory
này bộ nhớ này I này tức cả input output
này kiểu dạng là kiểu đọc ghi tốn kiểu
CPU đọc ghi các thứ thứ đấy cứ CPU các
thứ thứ ở đây và thứ hai là time như này
thì thường time này là thời gian truy
vấn Thời v xử lý thì thằng SQL Nói chung
nó vẫn hướng tố ưu về nó sẽ lấy những
cái mà tốn tham ít
nhất nhưng mà không không có nghĩa là
cost của nó sẽ thấp nhất đúng không
nghĩa là ví dụ Giả sử tôi câu truy vấn
này của tôi th nó sẽ ít hơn nó sẽ ngắn
hơn nhưng mà cái cost của nó cái CPU nó
nó tạo hàng bảng tem nữa mà thì chắc
chắn là nó sẽ tốn cost ít nhất là về
memory hơn rồi đúng không đấy anh ấy bảo
là thay bình như này thì em cứ cho bình
thường thôi nhưng mà mình sẽ en thêm ở
đây không biết ông mấy ông biết vụ này
không B chd bằng cái gì đó như này Ừ lúc
này tôi mới vỡ ra kiểu tôi Thực ra tôi
có biết vụ en này on như này rồi nhưng
là bản chất Hồi đấy tôi không hiểu không
hiểu là viết như này khác gì viết kiểu
We rồi B như này Đâu nhưng nhưng mà anh
ấy nói là kiểu En Như này chính là kiểu
viết kiểu kia đấy Đó là kiểu bản thân là
lúc mà Joy nó đã Que cho mình trước rồi
bởi vì que BD như này nó khác nhé Nếu mà
ghi kiểu như này nó khác luôn kiểu như
này là ông Joy xừ rồi ông mới que Còn
đây là ông ông que luôn lúc mà on
thích kỹ lắm vì tôi tôi thường haay nói
nó không không phải là ý gì Nhưng mà
chắc chắn là các thầy cô một là lý
thuyết các thầy cô nắm vững nhưng mà các
thầy cô cũng ngại Giải thích hai là các
thầy cô không kinh nghiệm thực tế Làm
liên quan đến triệu các thứ các thứ vì
thực tế là SQL Nói chung thì thực ra là
nhiều người dùng
bản ghi nó vẫn phù hợp trên 1 triệu Thực
ra nhiều người tính phương án khác
rồi dùng time table thì sao ạ time table
thì tốn về cost memory tự nhiên em sinh
một bảng Ảo ra code để mà xử lý cái dữ
liệu cho cái vụ select đấy nó không tốt
thực tế Hồi trước tôi dạy về cái vụ equ
trên s mấy ông cũng có nhớ rồi đó là
kiểu thậm chí là nếu mà câu này chạy
nhiều mình có thể đẩy nó vào view này
hoặc là vào function đấy nó cũng có rất
nhiều cái lợi đúng
em em cứ Bây giờ em cứ thêm cái explain
ở trước cái select em sẽ rõ mà Em sẽ
thấy cái cost nó sẽ nhì lên hẳn cao như
nào khi mà em dùng time table hoặc em
dùng kiểu này em sẽ so sánh được cái
time với cái cost thôi mà đúng
không
cái cái sound table kia chính là tem
table đấy Đấy nó sinh ra kiểu thế thì
memory V vỡ mồm
truy vấn thuần lắm nhưng mà đấy thì gần
đây anh đi cái sự kiện thì người ta cũng
phân tích về cái vụ này đó là là thực tế
là de Nói chung người ra không mạnh với
SQL đâu nên là chuẩn là dep sẽ làm phải
tách riêng cái bit logic với cái
technical logic sang hai chỗ khác nhau
có những dep không dành không mạnh về
SQL đúng không Thì không được viết câu
SQL vì đôi khi ông viết câu SQL mà sai
ông làm treo luôn cả hệ thống thì vỡ mồm
đúng không thì chuẩn là có những dep sẽ
chỉ viết business logic nghĩa là bạn ấy
biết nghiệp vụ cần phải làm gì thôi Và
bạn ấy sẽ code theo kiểu gì gì đó thôi
ví dụ giả sử như bạn kia vừa nói là dùng
orm đúng không Nghĩa là không không hẳn
là biết được là bên trong nó thực sự là
truy vấn cái gì Giả sử tôi sẽ có có
customer đây tôi gọi đến kiểu dạng get
info này đấy rồi tôi xử lý với cái đoạn
sau đấy xử lý cái gì đó sau đó này thì
đấy việc của cái ông dep làm business
nhưng mà nhưng mà cái hàm này này bản
chất nó làm cái gì thì cái ông cái ông
kia sẽ cái ông chuyên sâu ấy thì ông sẽ
viết câu SQL Thuần ở trong này những cái
câu SQL kiểu rất là dị ở trong này kiểu
ông ấy chuyên về SQL ông biết làm tối ưu
còn cái ông ông đép làm business ông chỉ
quan tâm là Ừ có cái hàm gọi để lên
thông tin tạo gọi và nó cứ đầy đủ thông
tin thế thôi không cần quan tâm về việc
câu truy vấn eql nó như nào đấy làm như
thế thì mình sẽ rõ ràng ra hơn
việc logic thừ thử nó theo opop đây Nó
là kiểu không Không hẳn là op lắm đâu nó
design pattern ấy Kiểu kiểu làm nó kiểu
dạng là chia nhỏ nhỏ những cái layer ra
có những thứ không được động và cái thứ
kia nó là nào giống mvc
mvc là cũng tách biệt riêng giữa m chữ
vữ C đúng không nhưng mvc tôi tôi bị
nghe hôm sự kiện ấy bảo là mvc nghe nó
vẫn sôi thịt quá tức C nó vẫn còn ăn
liền quá đôi khi có những cái logic Em
không biết vứt vào đâu Em vứt là mod hay
em vứt controller bởi vì nó liên quan
đến nhiều mod thì em vứt vào đâu hạn thế
như bản chất là mình vẫn phải tách nhỏ
ra cái nhỏ nhỏ nhỏ ra hơn nữa ở những
cái tầng khác
nhau Nói chung là tôi thì tôi cũng nghe
thế thôi tôi cũng không hẳn là C code
chuyên nghiệ M mấy vụ đấy lắm nên là
sẽ sẽ cần à Gì
à Nói chung là sẽ cần có một người thiết
kế chuẩn mấy cái này r mình làm theo nó
hợp lý
bác b tôi toàn gọi là B gần đây tôi biết
là phát lm sai nó back C back back back
Ừ đúng rồi nó back backend
Ờ tiếp tục dùng larel
Ờ thì tôi có nói chắc là sang năm tôi sẽ
Khi nào có thời gian thì tôi sẽ tổng hợp
lại một khóa học cơ bản à không phải cơ
bản mà chuyên nghiệp và bài bản hơn đấy
sau và chắc là cũng sẽ larel vì tôi
chuyên cái đấy larel và để sầu về design
button với SQL
nữa chắc là sẽ là đăng video thôi Nếu mà
thời gian đấy
end Có ổn hơn không
Ừ cái này phải ngược lại mới đúng nghĩa
là có kiến
thức back end thì về sau em làm ba được
vì về cơ bản thì dep về sau mình mãi
không làm dep được đâu Kiểu gì về sau
mình nên làm hng khác thì ba ổn hơn
nhiều ba lưng cao và ít cạnh tranh hơn
Hiện tại thì đúng là cạnh tranh cũng bắt
đầu lớn đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà Mấy ông
bia Nói chung bây giờ có biết code đâu V
tự nhiên một thằng biết code thì rõ ràng
cạnh tranh hơn mấy ông kia
năm nay có offline G2 team không Năm nay
chắc là không rồi cuối năm mất rồi định
năm nay thự ra định offline ở trong Đà
Nẵng ấy nhưng mà tôi năm nay có khá
nhiều vấn đề nên là tôi không đi đâu
được chắc là sang năm tôi sẽ làm một
chuyến vào Đà Nẵng để xem cơ sở vật chất
mọi thứ trong đấy thế nào x thu sếp để
làm thấy tôi dự định là thế nhưng mà vẫn
hỏi ý kiến Các sếp cấp trên
có bắt đầu từ bây giờ mình sẽ livestream
lại vào tối thứ ba và thứ năm hàng
chung về sau Nói chung là các bạn ở các
công ty chắc là công ty không phải đủ to
chứ vài công ty đủ to về sau là ông
không có chuyện được truy vấn hỏng ở
trong DB hay biết được DB có những bảng
hay những cột nào Đâu M ông đều phải gọi
những cái kiểu như này hết ông không
được trực tiếp viết câu eql không được
biết được thực sự là DB có gì còn nếu mà
ông có viết ấy thì có một vài công ty nó
sẽ viết hẳn cái View cho ông và viết hẳn
function và ông chỉ được gọi và view và
gọi function chứ bản chất là ông không
được động vào chính xác vào đến cái bảng
để ông biết được là cái bảng gồm những
cái cột gì đâu nên là nói chung là nó
cũng là một lớp bảo mật mà hồi mà tôi
dạy về view cũng cả ph chân tôi có vụ
nói vụ đấy này thì nó cũng nhanh và bảo
mật hơn
nữa em hết hạn
Một Security premium
tôi tôi có một năm cái đấy tôi cũng
không dùng tính năng gì ở đấy tôi chịu
chắc Cùng lắm Được mỗi cái tính năng là
kiểu
Ờ biết được người khác đã xem mình khi
mà bạn ấy dùng bản
Security kia chặn được đã xem mà cũng
hay
Này chị muốn lời cảm ơn chia sẻ cách đây
ha năm trước ha năm trước và giúp đỡ rất
nhiều khó thăng của đại dịch đặc biệt
câu chuyện Lỡ giải xở số của anh Ừ đúng
rồi Tôi quên mất tôi ẩn cái nên ẩn cái
email này lỗi tôi làm để tôi ẩn luôn
nhạy cảm quá nhạy cảm
quá coi như không thấy gì
tôi có kiểu
Ờ có kiểu mở thu thập email code để mấy
ông không vào Nếu giả sử mấy ông nào sợ
kiểu dạng vào nhắn tin chửi chẳng hạn
nhiều ông Spam mà cũng có A fan nữa
không phải Không đâu mà antifan Ở đâu
cũng có thôi nhưng mà vì vụ có lưu lại
email nên mấy không sợ không dám
vào Spam nữa hay kiểu
Chắc là không đâu vì tôi không chuyên về
về JavaScript lắm nhưng mà tôi bản thân
tôi làm được
view mà tôi không hề học mấy nghĩa là
cũng bắt trước code r anh em trên công
ty tất cả có nền tảng về ja Script thôi
Tôi nghĩ là đủ thừa sức làm view rồi nên
không khó lắm
ạ Không đừng có hướng gì cho cái đấy sợ
lắm thôi trước sinh viên tôi từng cuồng
x tôi phải khuyên mãi nó mới B bỏ ông
nhảy sang Java Còn đỡ hơn không
ạ đừng đừng đừng hướng đi s gì làm
nháy nháy á Tại sao vậy anh á Bởi vì thứ
nhất là nó tính ra nó là ngôn ngữ cũ rồi
kiểu bây giờ ít thứ áp dụng nó lắm thứ
hai là
mọi thứ bởi vì nó nó cũ nên là tài liệu
mọi thứ cơ hội làm việc của nó cũng ít
Bởi vì bây giờ tuyển chỉ tuyển kiểu
không không mấy n nơi nào tuyển fester
đâu Đúng rồi có ông kia khuyên học cô
Lang cũng là một cái hay Tôi vẫn nhớ là
là cái này đang ghi âm chẳng mình có nên
nói nhỉ kểu cái lần cuối Tôi đi sự kiện
larel Việt Nam có một anh cũng buột
miệng bảo bây giờ nhảy sang gỗ Lang mà
học em
ạ không
Thế kiểu nói chung là nghĩa là
anh anh đấy Kiểu ở công ty anh làm song
song cả larel và goan nghĩa là cái gì
khó mà larel không áp dụng được thì nhy
nhảy sang goang anh làm kiểu
thế ra cũng là muốn ng mạnh kiểu nó cũng
fer dịng cộng luôn game BL à nhưng mà
nói chung là mà cũng ừ thì làm game Thì
Ừ làm game thì chắc là vẫn động x được
nhưng mà làm game thì ông phải giỏi toán
nhá
ơ mấy ông này cũng nằm vù hết này Mấy
ông cũng biết được ạ sợ thật thế mà hôm
mấy không gặp mấy
mà dạy ngôn ngữ khác chắc là tôi chuyên
về larel thôi Bây giờ sang bây giờ về
về bên FPT Người ta bảo tôi một là tôi
dạy Note hai là tôi dạy Java hoặc dnet
xong rồi tôi bảo mấy cái đấy em không
giỏi bây giờ bảo mẹ em dạy em em có thể
học nhưng mà em sẽ không có nhiều kinh
nghiệm bây giờ để em dạy p với larel em
sẽ đảm bảo đầu ra cho các anh còn không
thì thôi Hình như là em tôi thương lượng
sao vụ đấy hình như bên đây Bắt đầu
Chuẩn bị có thêm hẳn một cái gọi là một
cái chương trình mới chỉ tôi viết từ đầu
SQL này đấy bạn học SQL thì chắc là bạn
còn cảm thấy hay chứ bạn học tôi từ mấy
cái kiểu playlist khác thì có khi bạn
nhìn tôi ánh mắt
à T gi không làm pp như đối với
tế Ví dụ web bán hàng mà larel và g Hình
như ông ấy cũng hỏi cái này trên discord
thì phải tôi cũng né né trả lời câu này
bởi vì tôi cũng không biết lắm tôi triển
khai con web chạy bằng larel thì tôi
biết đơn giản thôi code pp đẩy lên react
thì tôi không biết nên là chắc là ông
đến xem trên mạng không thiếu đâu hoặc
là và hỏi hỏi thẳng bên thuê hosting ấy
thuê hosting ở bên Việt Nam tôi gần đây
tôi thuê ở bên
A tôi có thưởng hay tôi nhiều lúc tôi
cất nhắc có phải nên có nên nói hẳn ra
tên cụ thể không sợ là
họ sợ lại bị cho là quảng cáo cho dù
mình chẳng được ăn đồng nào cả thôi kệ
ví dụ là tôi thuê hosting ở bên Tino hot
à Thì bên đấy người Việt mà nên là hỏi
thằng tiếng Việt và bên này có vẻ dành
về công nghệ phết tôi hỏi họ mấy cái
kiểu về công đương nhiên không hỏi về
code nhá Nhưng mà hỏi các thứ thứ họ chỉ
cho chuẩn phết thứ thì chỉnh chỉnh các
thứ hỏi họ nói chung là thôi Ở bên họ
thì kiểu gì họ sẽ phải hỗ trợ các thứ à
đấy cả thầy nguyện gần đây cũng được gặp
bắ tay anh ấy nữa nhưng mà chư Chắc là
chưa được Chat với thầy nguyện bao giờ
đâu Nhưng mà như ông hiểu đì tôi nghĩa
là ông thuê họ sinh bên đấy Bây giờ bảo
là kiểu bên đấy hỗ trợ để mà đẩy code
lên thì chắc họ họ hỗ trợ được thôi
không thì ông không thuê nữa thì họ lại
mất khách hàng đúng không Nói chung là
tôi cảm thấy nó đỡ hơn hồi trước tôi
thuê ở bên
hostinger kiểu chat cho nó C thử thử đặc
biệt là cái hồi mà mình không thuê hot
nữa chỉ mua tên miền bên đấy thuê tên
miền bên đấy Uầy nó kiểu support chẳng t
tận tâm nữa tệ
ty nữa trai h hết khóa larel rồi chuyển
ngôn ngữ khác hay chuyển luôn
ạ theo Hồi trước mình khuyên Thì mình
vẫn thường hay nói đó là tôi dạy mấy ông
về lập trình chứ không phải dạy về ngôn
ngữ nên là các bạn hỏi tôi về ngôn ngữ
thì tôi sẽ kiểu Không khuyên được một
cái gì cả dạy về lập trình tức là tôi
muốn cho mấy ông hiểu về thứ nhất là
faceb thứ ai là kiểu kiểu kiểu tư duy
lập trình r các thứ mọi thứ Nên là tôi
nghĩ là là kiểu gì mấy ông cũng nên hoàn
hành hết một khóa để mấy ông hiểu được
bản chất làm một cái phần mềm nó nó từ
đầu đến cuối nó nên như th nào rồi mấy
ông chuyển làm sang bất kỳ khác đều được
giống như là bây giờ bảo tôi nhảy sang
mảng khác Thực ra tôi vẫn nhảy
được đừng nghĩ là mình nó không phải học
như là ngôn ngữ tự nhiên mình học tiếng
nói theo kiểu là bây giờ tiếng Trung hết
hot rồi Em học tiếng Nga hay tiếng Đức
được không không nó không phải như thế
ông học ngôn ngữ này nhảy sang ngôn ngữ
khác chẳng vấn đề gì cả đúng rồi học học
mà học xong rồi ông sẽ thấy thằng nào
cũng giống thằng nào thôi nó chỉ khác
nhau một vài cái nó ưu và nhược rõ ràng
Còn một khi mà ông không thấy được đấy
điều đấy chứng tỏ ông vẫn chưa học đủ
rồi thì ông càng phải
lọc Nếu có thể Open xộc thì đóng góp
code cùng nhé thực tế là có đấy thế nên
là tôi mới định code livestream code đó
tôi bản chất là tôi không muốn không
không ý định giấu việc code đấy và tôi
muốn anh em vào Đóng góp cùng nữa về cái
thứ nhất là cái tiện ích Thứ hai là cả
cái code của cả trang web đấy nhưng mà
đương nhiên là nó hơn nhược điểm Nếu mà
code trang web mà để lộ ra thật ra là
tôi vẫn sợ có ông nào ôm về ông ấy làm
cái khác C không thích kiểu đấy thôi
nhưng
mà nhưng mà tôi vẫn muốn là anh em có
thể C nó ngó vào vì code của mình cũng
không phải code xị nhất khát vào sẽ bổ
sung hay hỗ trợ gì mình thậm chí là góp
ý gì đó cũng là đủ rồi mình cảm thấy nó
một cái dự án Open tập thể mà đúng không
cái key rồi mấy ông nhìn thấy key Tôi
định làm cái đấy là kiểu liên quan đến
api nhiều bên mà cả rất nhiều mạng xã
hội nữa phải ẩn hết
Key
g grpc chưa nge bâ giờ chắc là không
repos
repository như vậy hay gặp L cho nhiều
bảng là tên hàm khó lắm Làm sao để fix
cái này đến giờ dùng Chat BT rồi ông có
hẳn toàn bộ C code đấy vào rồi bà đặt
tên function này là như
Chắc là tham khảo code của người đi
trước xong rồi Kiểu cũng làm dần thôi
Chỉ có thể làm dần rồi xong rồi quen dần
thôi tôi Thực ra tôi là người cũng hơi
bị đọc lướt với không đọc kỹ tài liệu
lắm vì tôi không phải là con người mà
nói thẳng như là tôi cảm thấy tôi may
mắn chưa đại học bởi vì lên lại học chắc
là vì tôi cũng không học đại học nữa nên
cái việc mà ngồi đọc kỹ tài liệu xong
rồi mà bắt đầu làm ấy tôi không làm được
Tôi muốn vừa làm vừa kiểu code hơn hả
Hôm nay stream Có
720 không biết là do máy hay là do là
cái này chỉ hỗ trợ thế nhỉ xem nào
Ơ đợi
tí 720 rồi
mạng mình có tệ lắm đâu
16 1600 nhân
đây không biết làm làm này chỉnh hơn
luôn ông nào mà chuyên về livestream thì
chắc là h có thể về sau nhắn tin riêng
hỗ trợ tôi mấy cái vụ này tôi cũng không
không chỉnh mấy đâu Tôi dùng cái mặc
định của nó
là có khi là kiểu cao nhất chỉ được thế
vì tôi nhớ là tôi vừa nãy tôi có bấm vào
bên video gi tôi chọn cái cao nhất rồi
hình như nó cũng chỉ thế này
rồi chắc tí có xem lại chư tí em nhắc
anh anh xem lại cho
đã học mà rồii Gần đây tôi có học lên
thông lên để lấy cái bằng để mà về sau
đi dạy thôi chứ tôi cũng không học đại
học chứng quy nên là cái việc đọc tài
liệu kiểu đọc Nghiên cứu kỹ rồi mới code
thì không phù hợp với tôi lắm Tôi cảm
thấy là việc học giống kiểu học nghề như
này phù hợp hơn đó là
học sẽ vừa học lý thuyết vừa thực hành
và thực hành chiếm nhiều hơn thì tôi
thấy hiểu
h Anh có biết ai tên Nguyễn Mỹ Huyền
không không
đầu tôi faceb JavaScript đầu tiên tôi
động vào Angola 2 Nhưng bây giờ nó khác
nhiều lắm
rồi
làm một trong web khi thanh toán ngân
hàng bên thứ ba thì mình xài cái gì vậy
Mấy anh cái này ông hỏi trên discord ấy
có vài bạn trả lời cho nhưng mà tôi
thường anh thấy là có nhiều bên bâ giờ
chia sẻ nhiều lắm hình như Việt QR hay
gì đó nhiều bên
Ờ cái khóa larel của tôi có dạy Qua MC
Op cơ bản đấy không thể học trước cũng
được Ông học xong Xong rồi ông về sau
học p nó cũng không ảnh hưởng gì đâu ai
có thể thay thể coder được không ai mình
bản chất là mấy ông phải phân biệt nha
Thực ra để trả lời ngắn gọn thì là không
và để trả lời dài dòng thì mấy ông sẽ
phải hiểu được bản chất mình học lập
trình là code là để mình gần như là biến
máy tính thành một cái công cụ cho mình
mình học ngôn ngữ code là code là cái
ngôn ngữ để mà nói chuyện giao tiếp đ
máy để máy phục vụ cho mình nên ngay từ
lúc đầu đó là ai cũng thế nó sinh ra để
hỗ trợ cho mình mình đừng bị bị cái cái
cái thứ sinh ra nó còn thay thế được
mình thì thế hệ sai quá đúng không Mình
ng nhưng mà nó sẽ nhược điểm không phải
nhược điểm mà nó sẽ là một cái cạnh
tranh đó là mấy ông sợ ai thay thế thì
mấy ông phải biến nó thành ưu thnh à
nhược thành ưu tức cả mấy ông
sẽ phải học cách sử dụng nó học cách
kiểu tối ưu để sử dụng được nó không thì
đúng là nó sẽ th thế được ông khi ông
code không tốt hơn được nó ví dụ Giả sử
ông dùng nó để x ra code thì ông phải
biết cách để mà kiểu làm tối ưu hơn làm
sao nó trả lời đúng hơn và và gọi là
trên Ning được cho nó để nó phục vụ cho
mình chứ Bây giờ ông còn thông minh kém
M ai thì đúng là nó sẽ thay thế ông thật
hình như tôi nói đấy tôi sẽ có ý tưởng
tôi TH là một người rất nghĩ ra rất
nhiều ý tưởng được nên là tôi sẽ kiểu
khi có ý tưởng tôi nghĩ ra cách kiểu tìm
cách để xử lý kiểu rạch làm ra những
phần mềm nói chung là xong rồi chia sẻ
cho cộng đồng nữa có thể cộng đồng đóng
góp ý kiến cũng như là mình cảm thấy là
cái thứ mình làm được trân trọng vân vân
thì nói chung là càng ngày càng phát
triển thì thì nó nâng trình bản thân lên
tôi học trường nghề BK cái này Thực ra
tôi công khai hết ở trên trang Facebook
ấy mấy ông có thể xem tôi cũng chẳng
giấu gì
bao giờ khó mà thay đổi được á bây giờ
chỉ có tắt live đi được thôi nên chắc là
để buổi sau
Ờ chị hỏi được mấy cái cơ bản
Ờ chat DT Thực ra nó rất là mạnh nhá ông
không phải hỏi một cơ bản đâu hỏi mà
kiểu chên sâu nó vẫn trả lời đấy ông
copy hẳn đạn code của ông vào xong rồi
ông bảo là nó kiểu tối ưu Hay là để nói
chung là nó trả lời lần một lần hai nó
sẽ sai bởi vì bản chất nó chưa hiểu được
cái kiểu cái tình huống của ông gặp phải
ông phải giải thích kỹ cho nó Và bắt nó
generate lại nhiều càng generate nó bản
chất nó sẽ càng học kỹ hơn này ông gen
lại liên tục đấy xong ông sẽ phải nói cụ
thể hơn các thứ thứ thì nó sẽ hiểu hơn
tôi dùng Chat ctivity Nói chung là tôi
dùng tận dụng tôi cảm thấy là dùng rất
là triệt để luôn kiểu để mà kiểu nói
chung là nó là ai Tức là cái tên nó nói
đến tất cả có nghĩa là nó đang phải học
dần ông gửi đoạn code ví dụ Giả sử Bây
giờ bọn ông bọn ông gửi tôi một đoạn
code kể cả tôi là sinio nữa nữa tôi đọc
lúc đầu tôi cũng chẳng hiểu mục đích ông
đang định muốn làm cái gì cả tôi sẽ phải
suy nghĩ một lúc đúng không việc nó trả
lời cho ông cũng là lúc nó đang suy nghĩ
Ông hỏi lại nó một lần nữa là nó suy
nghĩ thêm một lần nữa nó lại trên thê
một lần nữa nên càng trên nó sẽ càng tốt
nên là nên là ông đừng cói thường nó về
việc học của nó nó học nó tốt hơn rất
rất nhiều
Đấy Như Tôi vừa ví dụ đây bây giờ kể cả
một sen ông gửi cho họ một đoạn code Họ
đọc họ phải ngẫm nghĩ một lúc họ mới trả
lời được cho ông và trả lời lúc đầu chưa
chuẩn vì họ chưa ngẫm đủ lâu Xong rồi
ông hỏi lại họ một phát nữa họ sẽ ngẫm
lại phát nữa thì họ sẽ có cách trả lời
khác A nó cũng giống hệ thế không khác
gì
chất là Đấy ông ông trên cho nó ông sẽ
thấy nó học nhanh lắm và lúc mà nó Nó
đang trả lời trả lời dần này nó vẫn đang
nghĩ nghĩ này ông đừng có stop để nó Hãy
để nó một mạch nó nghĩ sao ông lại hỏi
lại chi tiết đôi khi là tôi cứ thường
anh nói là r như này là như này liên tục
liên tục liên tục để cho nó kiểu nó sẽ
nó lại trên lại một phát nữa hay cực cứ
thấy thể trên câu trả lời nó sẽ càng
càng chuẩn hơn
code Tôi áp dụng tôi mở cho mấy ông Xem
liên tục thì mấy ông sẽ thấy cái cách
tôi sử dụng ai cũng cũng một cách đúng
không
ừ thằng thằng copilot có cái chat rồi
đấy m không thể dùng copilot cũng được
Cho dù là tôi cảm thấy là
copilot hiện tại ở bên p Storm thì đang
chưa Chat trực tiếp được còn vs code
Hình như Chat trực tiếp được rồi thì C
pilot về cơ bản tôi thấy nó sẽ có thể
ngon hơn vì bản chất là nó đọc code sẵn
của của của ông rồi chứ không phải giống
chat vity ông phải có code
nữa không copilot nó hơn chứ một thằng
chuyên về code hơn mà và nó đọc hẳn cái
dự án của ông kết h việc nó tham khảo
code từ trên github rồi còn một khi mà
ông cảm thấy nó không khôn có khi do
code của ông nó tệ nó không h Một hoặc
là hoặc là gì nhỉ hoặc là nó
nó ông đang code hẳn một cái mới mà trên
git Hub nó không có cái để mà học nên
thành ra là là nó không biết gợi ý ch
cái gì chứ copilot Tôi vẫn luôn đánh giá
cao hơn thằng chity vì nó sinh ra dành
ra code mà nó còn có trước thàng chity C
mà đúng
dùng Joy hay sub query tốt hơn ạ Ờ thứ
nhất là các bạn vẫn luôn bài toán là
dùng explain thứ hai
là
dùng hết một câu lệnh là nó hay nhưng vì
sao tôi cảm thấy là thực ra là đôi khi
chúng ta tách hẳn câu truy vấn ra nghĩa
là mình sẽ dùng mình sẽ truy vấn ra lấy
toàn bộ ID của một hàng xong mà mình cái
cái thằng thứ hai mình We In trong cái
danh sách ID đấy còn nhanh hơn rất nhiều
vì bản chất là ID nó là primary key thì
nó sẽ nó sẽ là nhanh nhất rồi nó hơn cả
Index vì PR key nhanh nhất rồi
à Đấy cũng là một cách nói chung là cái
này bây giờ để mà hỏi về cái lý thuyết
sq nó khó trả lời được lắm vì
Ờ nó còn phải theo thực tế của cái cái
cái ông muốn làm nữa nhưng mà để mà nói
gọn lại ấ với sq Nói chung ấy ông tra
câu này trên mạng ấy sẽ thấy luôn nói là
Joy tốt hơn vì SQL nó luôn Tối ư về Joy
còn sub bản thân là nó vẫn là truy vấn
lặp cứ thằng này lặp đi lặp lại Nên là
chắc chắn là nó sẽ tệ hơn
rồi Sắp tới có dạy thêm về cái gì không
Hay chỉ like code Không thực ra là thực
tế về sau tôi vẫn định kênh của tôi tên
là Block mà tôi vẫn định sẽ mang thiên
hướng vẫn Thiên hướng là chia sẻ góc
nhìn theo góc nhìn về mọi thứ thôi Nhưng
mà theo góc nhìn của một dân công nghệ
chứ không chỉ thuần là về mỗi code nhưng
mà Đúng là có thể là sẽ nhiều người
không thích Vì kiểu đúng kiểu thằng này
mày chỉ biết code chứ Mày biết cái gì mà
nói nhưng mà đấy theo góc nhìn của tôi
thôi góc nhìn khách quan của một người
dân công nghệ thì họ sẽ có logic riêng
của họ họ sẽ có góc nhìn khác đúng không
Ví dụ là họ họ tra cá cách tra Google
của chúng ta đã khác nhau rồi chẳng hạn
nghĩa là cách tiếp cận của cái thông tin
của mấy ông sẽ khác tôi chẳng hạn nhấy
ví dụ là tôi tra Đọc bài báo nó sẽ khác
Việc K Ông đọc bài
báo đừng dẫn nguồn từ voer là
được Anh cho em hỏi điu Lương thế nào
hợp lý K đúng giá trị mình tạo ra mà
không qu sức mình tôi hình như trước tôi
nhớ là có cái lời khuyên về cái đu lương
là ông cứ nói hẳn cái giá cao Xong rồi
ông anh anh kia nói à anh kiểu phòng vấn
mình sẽ nói ở giá thấp xong rồi lấy đoạn
giữa Thế là chuẩn nhất Đây là một cái
đấy một cái ví dụ thôi nhưng mà nhưng
thực tế ông này đang bảo fơ đúng không
fơ và interm ấy thì nói thật là đừng có
điu lương mấy gọi là mình chấp nhận là
mình đang học việc
mà còn khi mà ông lên hẳn là Junior
junor khác biệt hoàn toàn nhá Junior là
ông sẽ phải đ Còn với tôi Thì cứ tầm
thấp dưới thì mình chấp nhận người ta
trả mình thế nào tốt mình thế ấy V vì
mình biết đâu Mình biến thành cánh cánh
nặng người
ta còn một khi mình làm được việc rồi
thì mình không phải cánh nặng nữa thì
mình nhận mình điu lương của jio luôn
chứ fer Thì mình có quyề ý kiến thì mình
sẽ được thực tập là may rồi đấy theo góp
nhìn tôi
Đấy có vài ông ở đây biết voer này đúng
không cố hành voer
hai ngày live trùng ngày đi học hết chắc
là một em xem em chấp nhận Xem lại video
thôi Thực tế là tôi có thể chọn ngày
khác vì mấy ngày khác tôi vẫn đang rảnh
thôi nhưng mà gọi như nào nhỉ ờ Tôi muốn
theo cái lịch cũ mà lịch cũ mình là 357
mà nên theo lịch kiểu đấy cũng
hay Tôi nghĩ là chắc là tôi cũng sẽ phải
giữ c Đấy Bởi vì nếu mà để nói thì bây
giờ ông hình dung nhá Chủ nhật tôi đi
chơi Tôi đi chơi lại à Tôi đi chơi kiểu
cũng về muộn nên là thứ hai tôi đi làm
xong cả ngày tôi sẽ khá là mệt nên tối
về chắc là tôi sẽ hết sức đấy Chỉ mỗi
thế thôi Đấy và tối thứ Sáu thường là
mấy ông cũng kiểu tối thứ Sáu tối thứ
bảy tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng nên có thời
gian đi chơi Tôi cũng nghĩ là tôi cũng
sẽ đi chơi vì thứ bảy tôi nghỉ mà nên là
thành ra là có phải 3 năm thì nó sẽ lổn
nhất mà đúng không đấy Nghe hợp lý mà
Gần đây tôi cảm thấy là cái khả năng
thao Tùng thuyết phục của tôi cao hơn
được phết m không ạ cảm thấy biết cách
thao túng
hơn Đúng là không uổng công Hồi trước
vào V công ty đa
hẳn ý định dạy lại hẳn khóa đấy đâu vì
khóa đấy Công nhận là khá tâm huyết hết
rồi nhưng mà vì sau mấy ông tôi nhớ có
vài ông nhiều đang hỏi cái câu SQL À
đúng rồi có một ông hỏi nhờ tôi về cái
vụ gợi ý đô án
ông này trả lời nhá Hôm nay định
livestream hôm một tiếng tiếng 40 phút
rồi Chắc là để hôm sau nhớ Nhắc tôi tôi
hôm sau trả lời cho mấy ông
ấy em đang là kỳ sinh viên kỳ 3 larel
cần học cơ bản nh gì để đi đượcc tập
ạ Không em không nên nói dùng từ học cơ
bản mà là em cứ làm xong cái khóa larel
của anh kiểu dạng là một cái project 2
thì em không cần phải đi đượcc tập nữa
em xin làm junor luô luôn
được vì thực ra mấy ông cứ ham vì đi
thực tập nhanh nhất có thể mấy ông muốn
làm ph sơ mấy ông là in tơm nhanh để mà
muốn Va chạm thực tế là đến đấy Có rất
nhiều công ty ng ta chỉ vứt cho ông tài
liệu chứ người ta cũng không có có người
để mà kèm kèm cho mấy ông từng Ly từng
tí một khi mấy ông thà ngồi ở nhà tự làm
một cái dự án riêng xong rồi đến nhận
hẳn làm g còn tốt
hơn bởi vì mấy ông bây giờ đi phỏng vấn
mà Mấy ông không có gì để khoe cũng khó
mà xin được vào
larel đấy anh cho em link vào discord
được không có trong mô tả của video này
hình như tôi có để link đấy
Ờ em đang là sinh viên kỳ 3 FPT chuẩn bị
chọn combo Chuyên Ngành hẹp giải thích
n2.net không không biết cả hai không
biết giải thích thế nào về định hướng
học tập và công việc được
không em thử cái nào hoặc em chỉ cần đọc
qua tài liệu thằng nào mà thấy có vẻ dễ
đọc hơn thì em cứ đọc và làm thử thôi cả
như anh bảo thì ngôn ngữ nó không quan
trọng đâu
quan tâm về mấy cái Yêu cầu người ta ghi
tôi từng thấy người ta yêu cầu kiểu có
bằng đại học tôi vẫn đăng ký bình thường
th tôi rõ ràng tôi làm gì có bằng tôi
vẫn đăng ký thôi đừng quan tâm khi mà
một khi CV của ông đ ghi rõ những cái
kinh nghiệm thực không phải kinh nghiệm
thực tế mà những cái kiểu là những cái
dự án ông từng làm những cái project ông
từng làm ông ghi chi tiết cho tôi là
kiểu đã làm những cái gì trong đấy đã
học được những gì trong đấy nó xịn hơn
bao nhiêu về việc là kiểu kinh tôi từng
thấy có một ông Mộ năm ông phải nhảy ba
công ty liền cái kinh nghiệm thực tế của
ông ấy Kiểu nhìn cái quả cái danh sách
kinh nghiệm của ông đấy Kiểu sau 2 năm
đi làm kiểu sáu công ty công ty nào cũng
1 hai tháng người ta lúc đấy người ta
kiểu thấy kiểu chàng ngày chắc vào một
thái tháng bị đuổi đấy nó còn tệ hơn
nghĩa là mấy ông phải đừng có nghĩ về
kinh nghiệm thực tế nhiều bản chất là
Trung Quy gộp lại vẫn là ông rút ra được
gì từ những cái đấy khi mà Ông làm dự án
cá nhân ông vẫn rút ra được rất nhiều mà
chẳng qua code của ông chưa đủ chuyên
nghiệp thôi thì vào đấy họ chên Ninh nó
hết nhưng mà ông phải có tư duy và ông
phải có đam mê Cái đấy thể hiện qua
chứng cái dự án cá nhân của ông làm ông
làm những cái dự án cá nhân ông tâm
huyết hết cho nó ông khoe được trong CV
ta có cái để khoe rồi đúng
phải upline chụp công ty rồi
bàn thông qua trang
web không ạ Được không ạ đúng không
kiểu check in tại tiệm mới cho đặt món
thì tính năng này khả thi không Anh đơn
giản mà ở mỗi bàn em có một cái mã QR em
quét xong rồi Đương nhiên Thực ra nó
cũng có rủ do là thằng kia nó kiểu chụp
ảnh cái đấy rồi về nó đặt nhưng mà chạ
không đến nỗi thế đâu và mỗi bàn đấy mã
Q đấy tương ứng với một cái bàn luôn
kiểu thì anh thấy nhiều nơi làm vụ đấy
mà thì em sẽ kiểu thì sẽ kiểu tự động
đặt cho cái bàn đấy thôi đúng không dễ
mà
upline mà theo anh nhà thuyển dự có thể
để mắt đến không ạ
Ơ thì ông xem cái danh sách đoán Hồi
trước tôi cho mấy ông làm ý ví dụ là một
là pet Project là mấy ông tự
theo theo kiểu sử thích cá nhân của mấy
ông nhưng mà nó nên động vào api
nhiều hai là
nó phải có rất nhiều cái bài toán nghiệp
vụ hoặc là đấy theo một cái danh sách
Tôi từng bảo mấy ông thì nó có rất nhiều
kiểu bài toán phức tạp nghiệp vụ ấy thì
mấy ông thử làm cái đấy để mấy ông rèn
về việc là đặt mình ở phía khách hàng
phân tích để xem Khách hàng cần gì Xong
rồi làm những cái kiểu phân tích từ đầu
đến cuối về cơ sở liệu các thứ
hả ông có xem chỗ nào alti
ấy có phụ đấy à u ông xem ở đâu ra etic
vậy đỉnh ấ Ờ nhưng mà Đúng là công ty
tôi có Hồi trước có sử dụng etic nhưng à
đây đây đúng không Ờ ờ công ty tôi có
đang sử dụng elastic nhưng
mà nhưng mà tôi không nghĩa tôi sẽ dạy
nó đâu vì tôi cũng chỉ mới làm mức chẳng
biết dùng từ mức cơ bản hay không vì tôi
cũng làm vụ Script các th th cũng làng
nhàng phết rồi nhưng mà để dạy nó cũng
gọi nh
à dậy nó hơi bị Hơi bị
không biết dùng từ như nào
nhỉ Nó bị h hạn hẹp ấ vì rõ ràng là
không phải công ty nào cũng sử dụng cái
đấy nó cũng được tính là một no SQL đấy
không phải nhiều công ty áp dụng Tôi
nghĩ là tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông về SQL nó hợp
lý
Tôi có chữa mấy cái bài về phân tích
thiết kế DB ấ Nói chung là Chắc ông phải
xem lại chứ tôi không không nhớ được
video nào video
không
ạ không biết nn là gì không biết trả lời
câu này như nào
không thì chắc là cứ nên đi em ạ
apply f Java tại công ty lớn
như khi chuẩn bị
project project như tôi vừa nói là cũng
nên có bài toán nghiệm vụ rồi đúng không
còn kiến thức để làm về đặc biệt về java
thì chắc chắn ông phải nắm rõ về op xong
rồi op Nói chung thôi không cần phải đến
nỗi sâu về design pattern đâu nhưng mà
ông nắm rõ về những câu hỏi lý thuyết op
nữa để còn phỏng vấn nữa thì ông làm fơ
mà đúng không Đấy Nói chung là chỉ cần
biết op xong rồi làm một cái dự án thế
quá nghe được tiếng đấy luôn
á
em ngắm một công ty làm về shopify em
muốn clon một extension dùng trong
shopify cơ hội
Ừ đấy Đúng rồi nghĩa là em cũng để ý
biết được công ty làm về cái công nghệ
gì rồi xong rồi em cũng kiểu tìm hiểu
làm cái công nghệ đấy Thế cái việc tăng
cái tính tuyển dụng của em lên cao rồi
đúng
không cái khóa của anh thì nó có dạy về
lập trình nhưng mà chắc là không dạy về
tiện ích các thứ thứ thế đâu n em học
qua cái đấy để em làm một cái sản phẩm
riêng của em cũng được nhưng mà khóa của
anh về cơ bản nó vẫn kiểu mang Thiên
hướng là thực hành cũng nhiều nên là em
học cái đấy Em học Lý Viết xuông thì nó
không đủ đâu Còn nếu mà em làm thực hành
thì anh em làm thực hành luôn hẳn l reo
rồi mất rồi nên là đúng là anh cũng thấy
hơi bị cấn về việc là em học xong khóa
của anh xong rồi nhảy sang Ngô nữ
là gì
Chắc là bên đại học dậy đúng
tự động hóa các các nhiệm vụ Cơ sở tầ
giám sát ứng dụng quản lý hệ thống
cậy trước khi dep Ừ nó là là giống de
là em tìm hiểu dep cần học những cái gì
chắc cũng được đấy đúng không n trong
trên này nó mô tả rõ những cái thứ em
cần làm hết rồi này tra gole cái ra mà
chắc là không cần mình trả lời đâu vì
tôi cũng không biết đâu Làm sao copy một
h b từ DB này sang DB khác ạ Ông hỏi lại
đúng không Tôi vừa nãy nói rồi về câu
fql chắc là không có đâu vì không có
kiểu kết nối song song được như thế chắc
ông làm bằng code
viên và giới
trẻ cái đấy Thì ông làm cũng được nhưng
mà ông cũng phải chấp nhận là cái chất
xám của ông sẽ bị đem
dùng larel ạ Không bây giờ chủ yếu là
dùng Framework xong rồi dùng kiểu
platform các thứ chứ ít ai dùng thuần
lắm Anh có thành một buổi hướng dẫn
docker
á ai đồng nghiệp tôi đều biết là tôi sử
dụng đ cơ rất là kém tôi gần như là kiểu
cũng chỉ biết mấy câu lệnh cơ bản Tôi
cũng không biết hướng dẫn như nào Nhưng
như ám chỉ đến bây giờ tôi vẫn đủ dùng
rồi thì tôi nghĩ là mấy ông không khó gì
việc cài đặt dùng các thứ thứ đâu vì
kiểu gì sẽ có người đi trước hng chỉ cho
mình cái vụ
Tức là bây giờ có dân theo như tôi vừa
đọc đó là tôi tôi hiểu thì đó là kiểu
dạng là có vài bên kiểu thuê hoặc là
thậm chí là nhờ mấy ông kiểu làm mấy cái
làm mấy cái
kiểu kiểu dự dự
án làm mấy cái dự án để mà
bán thôi họ đem vào sử dụng cho công ty
của họ thôi thì nó là kiểu tận dụng chất
xám đâyy bán chất xám
học tiếng Anh á học tiếng Anh để mà có
cái bằng có cái chứng chỉ Thực ra cũng
cũng bình thường cho dù đến bản thân tôi
gi cũng chưa có cái chứng chỉ gì cả
nhưng mà cũng đừng có đánh đặt nặng nó
nếu mà trong ngành Công nghệ thông
tin
nhân rộng kiếm lúa hàng loạng
được hả Không biết bạn kia đang nói về
cái gì giờ theo Mobile nên học cái nào ạ
Chắc là học Java thôi hoặc là học react
à học Java tôi thấy là động cho nhiều
mảng hơn không phải mỗi mảng mile Tôi
thấy Java tiềm năng hơn
đấy post kh SQL nhiều không anh Chính
xác là SQL Nói chung về cả MQL cả PR và
cả SQL Server rồi Ờ à chính ra Ms SQL
rồi nên là à poet Nó kiểu nó sẽ chỉ khác
một vài Tí về cách gọi tên hàm thôi chứ
nó giống nhau
tôi nói là ông hỏi bên thuê trang cái
trang cho thuê hosting ấ nó hỗ trợ cho
bởi nhiều nên nhiều bên nó còn làm nhiều
kiểu khác nhau
nữa Nay Anh live đến mấy giờ rồi Vậy ạ
Chắc là tôi đang nghĩ là tôi chuẩn bị
nghỉ thôi vì hôm nay tâm sự cũng tương
đối khá nhiều và trả lời được hết mấy
câu này rồi Ờ Thực ra tôi sẽ nghĩ là tôi
sẽ buổi sau tôi sẽ live livestream code
một cái gì đó rồi tâm sự một ít sau hôm
này tương đối tâm sự cũng gọi là gọi là
như nh livestream trở lại thôi chứ không
thể tâm sự hết được tất cả mọi
thứ như là ờ Thực ra mấy cái câu hỏi
nhiều bạn nãy giờ hỏi Thực ra cũng gọi
là như tôi cảm thấy tôi không không phải
chuyên gia để trả lời mấy câu này vì mấy
bạn ấy hỏi về cả những cái thứ mà tôi
cũng chưa động vào bao giờ cái này chắc
là tra Google hoặc là hỏi tra gbt có khi
trả lời còn chuẩn hơn tôi trả lời nên
là ờ nên là cái này các bạn gọi nhở các
bạn phải tăng khả năng tự tra tìm kiếm
của mình hơn không cần phải nghe một anh
nào đó trên mạng nói cả vì bản thân là
mình ở Dân công nghệ mình phải biết cách
tra đừng ngại tra nó phải sằng lọp hơn
thế
thôi kể lại vụ xổ số
tâm sự này thì tôi có thể tâm sự được th
kiểu Hồi đấy là tôi hay chơi mấy cái
game ở bên nước ngoài ở mấy cái trang
nước ngoài thì hồi đấy là hồi lớp 7 tôi
nhớ chính xác lớp 7 bởi vì
à Xong rồi nó hiển thị cái pop up lên
à Kiểu về mấy cái sổ số các thứ các thứ
tôi hồi đấy kém tiếng Anh cũng tương đối
kém nên là kiểu không biết gì cứ Điền
bừa Thôi thôi điền thông tin các thứ các
thứ rồi ấ Ok thôi m Hồi đấy Chẳng thông
tin gì nhạy cảm cả nhưng mà về sau tự
nhiên có gửi mail thông báo tôi là tôi
được trúng thổ số cái đấy là photo à hay
cái gì gì đó n tên nó nói lên là mình
không mất tiền đâ cái S số đấy rồi Nó
không bảo mình phải nạp tiền để nhận
tiền đâu nhá nên tôi cũng nghĩa là nó uy
tín Ờ thổ số đấy ở bên Mỹ thì phải Ờ tôi
trúng được giải triệu
đô một cái một tấm x 1 triệu đô C một
cái nữa là giải giải gì nhở giải khuyến
khích à Là được 300 đô nữa đấy Nói chung
đ chúng đ Hai giải mỗi tội là tôi hố kèm
tiếng Anh tôi ghi address tôi ghi là 723
đấy Đấy do Tôi nhớ Tôi học lớp 7 Lãng cả
là à
Ờ nói chung là gọi là trúng thế không
biết trúng thứ nhất là không biết được
có trúng thật hay không nhưng mà Nếu giả
sử trúng Thế thì chắc là thứ nhất là Ghi
sai địa chỉ nên chắc chắn là không được
nhận vì tôi nhớ về sau tôi đọc lại cái
mấy cái ru của nó mấy cái quy định của
nó thứ nhất là trên 18 tuổi mới được
nhận thứ hai là phải ghi đúng địa chỉ để
họ có thể liên lạc lại được nhưng mà
chắc là nó không ghi cụ thể là là bắt
buộc tại ở Mỹ đâu Nên chắc là có khi
nước ngoài vẫn chấp nhận được nhưng mà
chắc là tôi ghi sai quá nhiều nên là gọi
là họ không thể liên lạc được cũng đúng
thôi cái việc là
Ờ tôi cảm thấy cũng may mắn khi mà không
không trúng biết đâu trúng thì cuộc đời
tôi gi sẽ không ngồi đây đúng không Chắc
chắn rồi không theo ngành này Có thể bây
giờ sang ngành quản lý tài chính để mà
đi quản lý tiền bản thân mình nên là
kiểu thực ra tôi cảm thấy cuộc sống tôi
mọi thứ được như bây giờ chắc chắn là
rất ngạc nhiên ghi được như bây giờ vì
hồi trước quá khứ mình nó khá
là màu màu đen nó hơi quá như Chắc chắn
là nó không phải là màu tươi sáng lắm
Ờ vì mình bản thân tôi thì trước n tôi
từ thấy tự hào mình được mỗi cái dầu H
vọng như Thực ra tôi chẳng có dầu Không
có gì trong tay tay cả đế bây giờ cũng
chẳng có gì trong tay cả không có một
cái gì là chắc chắn ở đây cả công việc
hiện tại nó vẫn không phải một cái cái
thứ gì đó chắc chắn một cái gì đó ổn
định đúng không biết đâu một con ai nào
đó lật mình lật đổ mình Bây giờ thì sao
đấy th duy nhất từ trước này tôi luôn
nghĩ là tôi có đó là mỗi hy vọng thôi
không phải là bạn bè không phải là một
cái gì đó cả hồi trước tôi cũng không có
bạn
người đang ngồi nghe Mình chém gió cũng
không biết là chính xác 100 hay không
hay Có phải ông treo máy nhưng mà
Ờ cảm thấy là mình đã bớt ler hơn à bớt
vô hình hơn so với cái hồi trước rất
nhiều cảm thấy may mắn hơn và cảm thấy
là do Hồi đấy tôi không có cái gì cả nên
là tôi C cắm đầu mà tôi làm cái thứ mà
tôi cho là đúng nên mới được như bây giờ
ờ nên tôi cảm thấy là cái việc lỡ đấy Nó
là một cái A nó là cái bước ngặt trong
cuộc đời đối với tôi tính là như thế là
tôi cảm thấy là chấp nhận điều đấy Nói
chung là ờ nhiều nhiều lúc chúng ta nhìn
ại quá khứ của chúng ta kiểu nghĩ là
chúng ta sẽ ân hận một cái gì đó Tôi là
tôi không muốn mình ân hận một cái gì cả
mỗi cái thứ đi qua để lại cho mình một
cái gì đó bài học hay một cái gì gì
đó đúng không Nói chung là thế nên là nó
mới làm nên được mình như bây giờ mà nên
tôi đều trân trọng nó hết đã bao giờ
thấy một ngày toàn điều tồi tệ chưa Tôi
tưởng trải qua rất nhiều ngày phải nói
đúng nghĩa là ví dụ hôm qua đối tôi cũng
là một ngày cũng không không tốt cả về
công việc vì hôm qua tôi lên công ty
cũng chẳng làm được việc gì mấy xong rồi
rất nhiều thứ nữa khiến là kiểu hôm qua
là một ngày đáng lẽ là một ngày kiểu
cũng tính là một ngày Tri Ân đấy chứ
công ty hôm qua tôi
C tôi đã gạ được công ty tôi hôm qua tổ
chức ngày cho nă giới mà nghĩa là hôm
qua tôi vừa có ngày năm giới vừa có ngày
nhà giáo cũng có nhiều người chúc đấy
nhưng hôm qua tính ra cũng là một ngày
kiểu tôi khá suy nghĩ khá là nhiều và
khá là trấm
à Tôi không bao giờ nghĩ rằng là tôi bị
đen đủi đâuu Tôi không bao đổ tại số
phận không Không hẳn là đổ tại bản thân
mình lắm nhưng mà cũng nghĩ là là chắc
là do mình nên là thành ra nó mới nó mới
xảy ra như thế chứ không đổ tại ch một
cái hoàn cảnh gì cả ví dụ là kiểu khi mà
hôm qua tôi bị tệ thế Tôi nghĩ là à hay
do bây giờ mình thay đổi rồi nên là mình
mới nghĩ như thế mình mới gặp những cái
tình huống như thế đấy Xong rồi Nếu mà
giả sử Tôi cảm thấy mà tôi không thích
điều đấy đúng không Tôi cảm thấy hôm qua
tôi khó chịu chẳng hạn thì làm thế nào
để mà mà mình không bị như thế nữa đặc
biệt là cái công ty tôi gần đây khi mà
làm việc với anh Bình khi là làm việc
chuyên nghiệp hơn thì tôi càng thay đổi
được cái tư duy từ tư duy lập trình sang
tư duy cuộc sống thôi Nó là kiểu là mình
không bao giờ được để mình vào rơi ở
trạng thái bị động mình luôn để mình ở
trong trạng thái chủ động Tức là sao khi
mà có một vấn đề gì đó Khi mà có một cái
bức gì đó xảy ra như thế Mình không
đường trước được mà nó tính là một Cái
Bấc cuộc đời đúng không đấy thì thứ nhất
là mình tìm được lý do để sinh ra được
cái Cái Bấc đấy để mình giải quyết nó
đúng không Nhưng mình cũng phải tìm cách
để phòng tránh để mình sẽ không bao giờ
phải gặp phải điều đấy nữa mình phải nắm
Thế Chủ động là mình sẽ khi mà nó mà có
thể sắp xảy ra chẳng hạn thì mình biết
được mình sẽ được cảnh báo hay gì gì đó
để mình sẽ không bị rơ vào tình huống
kiểu có lửa mới dập như thế nữa phải
phóng cháy hơn chợ cháy đúng không Đấy
Tôi cảm thấy là cuộc đời tôi học lập
chính nó thay đổi cho tôi tư duy rất rất
nhiều Tôi cảm thấy là tôi có khi tôi
không phù hợp ngành khác hồi trước tôi
từng nghĩ về việc là có thể rất nhiều
lúc là ông đôi khi kể ông làm tốt Một
cái thứ gì đó nhưng
mà nhưng mà nhớ đâu là ông không sinh ra
cho nó nó bị ngược kiểu thế cơ không
biết ông có bao giờ gặp kiểu thấy không
nhưng mà tôi tự nghe mấy kiểu đấy có
những người hát hay chẳng hạn nhiều
người sẽ bảo Ôi mày nên hợp đi làm ca sĩ
nhưng mà người ta không thích người ta
cảm thấy là cuộc đời họ họ không muốn
sinh ra Làm thế Có thể họ làm cái đấy
rất là tốt nhưng mà họ không thích kiểu
thế tôi làm hồi trước tôi Làm lập trình
vẫn tương đối ổn nhưng mà tôi cũng nghĩ
là tôi từng nghĩ việc là có khi mình
chọn xh ngành có khi là mình kiểu mình
làm được Nhưng thực sự có thể Nhữ đâu
mình không phù hợp vì sao nhưng mà khi
mà càm phí sau tôi học ngành này tôi cảm
thấy là nó thay đổi tôi tư duy rất nhiều
trong cuộc sống như thế nên là tôi nghĩ
là ừ nó đúng kiểu mình sinh ra mình phù
hợp với nó không biết về sau thì chắc
chắn là về sau sẽ làm ngành khác thôi
Làm mảng khác thôi nhưng mà kiểu Ít nhất
đến thời điểm tại thì mình vẫn phù hợp
với nó Anh làm ở công ty nào
á Tôi có chia sẻ ở trên Facebook ấy mấy
ông hỏi tôi về về mấy cái thông tin cá
nhân thì tôi chia sẻ hết trên Facebook
rồi mấy ông Thực ra mấy ông hỏi Chắc là
cũng chỉ để cho vui thôi chẳng nhớ gì
đâu nên là ông nào mà muốn tò mò thì cứ
lên Facebook ngồi mò một tí xong rồi
cũng thấy chán thôi thê ông kia có nhớ
kìa đỉnh
vãi buổi sau code trên m luôn hả Anh có
tôi tôi bây giờ cũng chỉ có mỗi một cái
máy má thôi nên tô không có lựa chọn nào
khác
đấy tôi cũng tâm sự cũng tương đối nhiều
Ủa hơn hai tiếng rồi Đúng là mình là một
thằng nó nhiều khác hy vọng là
Ừ cũng chắc là tôi nghĩ là tôi nhiều lúc
tôi nói nhiều thế cũng có cái lợi tôi sẽ
thao túng một phần nào đó mấy ông mấy
ông nghe kiểu Xuôi xuôi tai đôi khi mấy
ông có thể mở lên nghe đi Ngủ cũng là
một cái có vài ông dùng giọng tôi để đi
rung ngủ tôi biết
mà COD đơ nên dùng m hay Win anh nhỉ tôi
cá nhân tôi thấy là kiểu thứ nhất là gần
đây tôi code m tiện hơn vì nó chạy nhanh
hơn tốt hơn đặc biệt về cái quản
docker nên là tôi tính ra tôi vẫn đánh
giá m cao hơn Win còn như Ông em tôi
dùng thì dùng overt à
ờ nên là ông em thấy kiểu chạy trên đấy
Máy ảo ngon hơn thì tô thì chưa Tôi chưa
Dùng cái đấy Tôi cũng không biết đánh
giá như nào Nhưng cá nhân tôi thấy là
tôi sẽ không muốn quay lại Win ít nhất
như thế Cho dù tôi cảm thấy tiếc phết
tiếc ở khoản là tôi cũng gọi là cũng
dùng Win đủ lâu để tôi biết cắt phím tắt
rồi Rất rất nhiều cái rồi nhưng mà bây
giờ chắc là về sau chắc là sẽ dùng m cho
đến khi tôi cảm thấy là nó bất ổn Nó bất
tiện nhiều cái thì tôi sẽ cân nhắc
hả Long Winner không biết Long Winner là
không
À thường voer thường ny bảo là một khi
đã rời bỏ voer thì sẽ sẽ biến thành
Winner Nên là chắc là không phải là tôi
rồi tôi không ý định là tôi rời bỏ cái
vơ dù tôi chê bên đấy nhiều nào như cách
tôi chê wibu chẳng
hạn anh đã bọc bao nhiêu Quyến sách về
lập trình rồi Ui bây giờ mấy ông hỏi tôi
mấy câu này chắc là tôi chia sẻ xấu hổ
lắm tôi tôi đọc mỗi tôi đi Có dạo này
Ờ có gì nhỉ Hồi trước có cái quyển sách
dạy về nghề ở bên spum thì có đọc qua
này người trong môn nghề này
đấy tôi có muôn mua quyển clean code với
clean coder đến bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa đọc
vẫn là quyển sách đầu giường vẫn đang
mốc Nói chung là có đầu giường tôi bây
giờ phải 6 B quyển sách nhưng mà tôi
chưa đọc nên là thành ra là là không
tính
trên tôi đọc trên mạng nhiều hơn nhưng
mà tôi vẫn Công nhận tôi là thằng mà
sách nhá ví dụ điển hình tôi mở tab mới
rồi Tôi đang cài tiện xí Daily dep này
tôi thường đọp trên này này có vài cái
kiểu dạng như này giả sử không thích thì
mình không quan tâm kiểu tắt đi như này
chẳng hạn đấy xất ra những cái hay hơn
ví dụ Bấm cái này xong rồi Thậm chí là
do you like Z đề xất hơn chẳng hạn hay
phết ơ performance này best practic luôn
Ngon nhỉ giữ này thôi đấy Đấy được mà
đấy tôi đọc trên mạng cũng tương đối
nhiều hơn là nhưng mà tôi không thể chê
về sách nhá sách nó có chọn lọc hơn rất
rất nhiều nhưng mà Đúng là tôi hay quên
thật và cũng nói chung là cũng phải thời
gian để ngẫm nghĩ tôi khác với tư duy
nhiều người nhiều người đọc lấy số lượng
Tôi khẳng định luôn nhiều người đọc số
lượng tôi không hề thích cái đấy Tôi
không không muốn đọc theo lấy thành tích
kiểu như thế mình đọc mình phải ngẫm ĩ
mình mình đọc một quyển không hiểu mình
đọc đi đọc lại mà mình đọc mình C phải
thực hành nữa chứ không phải nhiều Ông
đọc lấy số lượng cứ thử thử thử nói
chung là tệ
lắm review máy web v đ á tôi không đọc
cụ thể mấy trang nào đâu n nào đó đâu
Ông thấy đấy tôi đọc đây tôi còn không
quan tâm nó thuộc trang nào tôi cứ bấm
vào tôi đọc thôi tôi không lên hẳn trang
nào đọc Hồi trước thì tôi có đọc chủ yếu
trên medium nữa nhưng mà một phần là gỡ
tài khoản rồi nên thh ra cũng không lên
đấy lướt nhiều nữa Nói chung đề xuất lên
thì đọc
Đúng không ông không biết Hồi trước tôi
mua quyển clean code và clean coder mua
bản gốc tiếng Anh của bên FBT shop mua
một mỗi một quyển hơn một củ bảy
Uầy Đúng là kiểu Hồi đấy mình đi dạy
mình nhiều tiền thật mình không biết
tiêu cái gì nên khi mà khi mà kiểu người
ta còn trả tiền mình mà tiền mặt xong
rồi nhét mấy chỗ củ vào trong túi quần
thấy cấn cấn nên muốn đi tiêu Hồi đấy
Công nhận là đáng ẽ mình nên bảo chuyển
nghĩ tôi đủ nhiều kinh nghiệm về cách
review các thứ thứ nhưng mà Đúng là gần
đây tôi cũng review nhiều hơn kiểu cũng
tối ưu các thứ thứ hơn nhưng mà đấy thì
hôm nào tôi sẽ mấy ông cứ chia sẻ code
mà kiểu không nhạy cảm lắm xong rồi bảo
tôi đánh giá qua tôi cũng sẽ chia sẻ mà
hồi trước trên discord có mấy ông tôi
từng review code của mấy ông nhiều này
này review cả tối ưu truy vấn này review
về cả CV các thứ th mấy ông đăng cái
discord này nhá Tôi quên mất phải khoe
nữa đó là mấy ông lên đây tạo thớt nhiều
vào xong rồi TC tôi để mà anh em có gì
cùng nhau cùng nhau kiểu review nhau
xong rồi Kiểu cùng góp ý tôi cũng không
phải là một người luôn đúng đúng không
Thì mấy ông phải đăng vào đấy để anh em
cùng thảo luận nhưng mà đương nhiên là
xóa hay là bỏ mấy thông tin nhạy cảm ra
mấy ông đôi khi đăng hết thông tin nhạy
cảm lên đặc biệt code của của công ty
chắc chắn không được nhá Đúng không
đấy Nói chung là tạo ra discord có cái
hay mà discord cốp đông mà đúng không
mình lên mình chia sẻ các thứ thứ trên
đây cùng nhau giúp nhau đi lên Xong rồi
Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ tạo một cái keo quên
mất tạo luôn mấy lần sẽ quên rồi
[Vỗ tay]
keo
kèo ăn chơi kèo đi chơi kèo tôi Tôi muốn
đăng kiểu các kèo lên đây nghĩa là chỉ
là ví dụ là sắp tới có mấy cái sự kiện
này anh em sẽ tạo kèo trên này này th
gọi gì à Ông kia còn bảo ra Zalo á Thôi
không muốn chê Zalo ở trên này Đâu nhưng
mà tôi sẽ đánh Nếu mà để làm cái thang
đánh giá những cái kiểu mình cái kiểu
như này ấ thì tôi sẽ thấy là discord
hiện tại tại với tôi là nó đang tiện ích
hơn telegram một tí telegram thì nó
không chia được nhóm kì này nhưng mà
telegram Thì đúng là rất nhiều công
nghiện nó xịn nhưng mà còn
Salo thì ông ông không biết được J2 team
chuyện đăng bài kiểu kiểu dạng các thứ
kiểu không jam thì đúng không ngại jam C
không ngại kiểu đăng bài mấy kiểu bx ph
lẫn nhau nhưng mà kiểu Thầy Tôi vẫn nhớ
là kiểu có bài mà nh Zalo là y rằng
không biết bài khen đ chê đế cả đội đép
của Zalo còn vào chê chịu buồn
mới á cái mới thì nhiều anh em ít anh em
tham gia lắm Tôi thấy discord này đặc
biệt là giới trẻ dùng nhiều mà vào đây
đang đặt Tết là gì nhở kèo à Kèo nó cứ
bị Trung chung nhưng mà tôi muốn nó
chung chung như thế nghĩa là bao gồm cả
kèo cà phê kéo Vãn uống Nói chung là
không phải mỗi tôi tự tạo kèo mấy ông tự
tạo kèo nhá nên làt tên là gì nhỉ kèo
nhá Nhưng mà đây để hết tiếng Anh
rồi Thôi để tiếng Việt
cái nhà cái không được tôi bảo cho chính
mấy ông đang cứ đặt tên này kéo
đi mấy ông thích có thể vào đấy bình
luận Uầy Hôm nay kiểu đúng đông người
vào thật đỉnh à kiểu bị spam ấy sợ
quá đây sẽ là đây đây nhóm này sẽ là
nhóm thảo luận này đấy Con Nhóm kia nhóm
Kèo
đấy nhóm này sẽ
là
à lên mọi kèo cuộc
là sự kiện cà phê ăn
uống không nhất thiết phải là ban quản
trị thự
tạo kèo mấy ông tự bom nhau xong rồi m
ông đổi lỗi do tôi không nhỉ vì tôi
không kiểm soát m cái này đâu à Ban Quản
trị không kiểm
soát và đảm
bảo kiểu miễn trừ trách nhiệm ấ nhưng mà
nói thế sớm có
bị
là để đăng thớt vào đây tặng kèo ấy để
anh cho Quyền vào đây chỉ có vào đây chỉ
tạo thớt
Thôi xem nào không biết làm thế nào để
trong này chỉ tạo thớt không không không
có chat trong
ngy sẽ là nơi chỉ tạo thớt thôi có chỉnh
mà nhỉ tí xem cách chỉnh như thế nào
À
đây view Channel manage Channel có th từ
manage cck invite Send message
khai
hết link link thì chắc là link Google
Map nhá Đừng link virus trong mà Nhá mệt
xóa th của nhau không
nhỉ Không My m
no m
Story gì đó chắc là tương đối rồi bùm
đấy các bạn đã
slug nhưng mà kiểu bị giới hạn tin nhắn
nên là cũng bỏ
rồi
à Giống J để quản lý dự án á cũng ngon
phết nhưng mà công ty tôi đang dùng zira
mất rồi đăng hết lên đấy mất
trước là câu hỏi mỗi ngày ấ xong Cuối
cùng thì kiểu anh em kiểu gọi nhề nh anh
em không vào đấy tôi hỏi vào đấy có vẻ
anh em không quan tâm nên là hơi
buồn đúng rồi không chat được trong kênh
này Bây giờ là kênh này sẽ chỉ tạo th
thôi các bạn bấn vào đây tạo th này
nhé
đấy
gim à
chưa các bạn vào đây tạo th được này
kiểu
koo web submit lên kéo luôn
web
submit 2023
viên này này h mày chia sẻ hơi đông
nhưng mà chắc là miễn phí chắc là mấy
ông vẫn thể đăng ký
Đó ok chưa Đấy là một cách lên Kèo đấy
hthub
Project Ừ Mấy ông biết nhiều công nghệ
nhỉ Tôi chưa dùng nhiều công nghệ như
thế đâu ok Ờ hôm nay nói qua cũng khá
nhiều rồi chẳng biết bây giờ tổng hợp
gồm những cái gì nữa nhưng mà Ờ hô nay
tâm sự khá là nhiều nếu mà không có họi
đáp gì thêm thì mấy ông cứ vào nhắn ở
trong discord nhá Tôi để ý discord nhiều
cực Tuy là bao nhiêu tin nhắn tôi cũng
đọc hết có những tin nhắn Tôi không trả
lời vì tôi không trả lời được nhá chứ
không phải chứ không phải là vì tôi
không đọc đâu nên là mấy ông cứ nhắn hết
trong đấy hoặc là nhắn tin riêng cũng
được Nếu mấy ông có tâm sự gì cả qua
Facebook hay là qua mọi nền tảng tôi vẫn
để tin nhắn
nay tạm nghỉ đã Ui hơn hai tiếng tâm sự
g tầm sự nhiều ấy tôi còn đi ăn tối phát
chào các shop nhá Hẹn các shop vào à đấy
vào cái kèo sắp từ